[Musique]
Artem Studentikov, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
a demandé de venir chez nous pour
représenter l'ambassade de Russie. Vous
êtes numéro 2 de l'ambassade de Russie,
ministre conseiller depuis un certain
temps maintenant.
Déjà 2 ans et demi.
Comment ça va ? Comment ça va ? Ça va
euh ça va. Euh vous voyez que euh le
travail à Paris est toujours très
intéressant. Il y a pas mal d'événements
qui se passent euh ce que ce que nous
euh donne beaucoup de boulot et voilà.
Euh c'est intéressant.
On vous a on vous a demandé de venir.
D'ailleurs, votre patron a changé. Euh
Alexandre Orlof est reparti à Moscou
après une longue carrière en France. Et
puis vous pouvez nous présenter votre
nouvel ambassadeur ?
Bon, j'espère que un jour vous allez
l'accueillir ici dans votre studio
quand il va parler français. Euh je sais
pas, on peut organiser interprétation,
c'est vraiment on peut toujours régler
ça. Monsieur Alessay Mchkov, c'est un
diplomate expérimenté et très haut
placé. Euh il était deux fois déjà
vice-ministre des affaires étrangères et
chaque fois il couvrait euh l'Europe du
Sud si vous voulez et toujours la
France.
Euh il était ambassadeur de la
Fédération de en Italie et euh donc
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très bien
l'Europe, qui s'occupe presque toute sa
carrière diplomatique de l'Europe. il a
fait beaucoup pour
[Musique]
approfondir et consolider les relations
entre la Russie et l'Union européenne
parce que à la fois il couvre les
relations de la Russie avec l'Union
européenne, avec le temps, avec le SE
avec toutes les organisations régionales
qui existent en en tout cas avec les
organisations principales qui existent
en Europe. Donc c'est quelqu'un très
européen et il est arrivé à Paris avec
un fort désir de
tourner la page et d'améliorer
de façon spectaculaire les relations
entre nos deux pays qui traverse, il
faut le dire, une période assez
compliquée.
Bon, c'est toujours un plaisir de vous
recevoir vous, ça fait déjà trois fois
qu'on vous reçoit. Vous avez toujours un
franelis aussi ciselé.
Merci. Merci bien. Pour moi, c'est ton
plaisir et euh je suis très content de
venir ici chez vous parce que nous
apprécions énormément cette possibilité
de voir en contact direct avec les
Français, avec surtout la jeunesse parce
que ce sont les jeunes qui s'intéressent
surtout à votre euh à votre site, à
votre à votre bon chaîne d'internet.
Euh
vous savez que je suis toujours
disponible et euh euh je peux vous dire
que j'aimerais bien de me retrouver ici
avec vous mais en présence de mes
collègues britanniques ou américains
pour avoir
ou suédois
ou suédois pour avoir euh en échange
courtois respectueux mais à la fois
ferme à la fois plutôt direct et franc.
Mais euh bon, pour l'instant, je suis
seul. Qui sait, peut-être un jour on va
se retrouver ensemble avec quelques avec
quelques collègues euh occidentaux.
On va on va délayer ce que vous venez de
dire. On avait proposé euh à vous,
l'ambassade de Russie d'interagir avec
l'ambassade américaine
qui n'a pas donné suite et on a demandé
à l'ambassade de Suède de venir
interagir avec nous et vous en face à
face avec nous qui n'a pas donné suite
non plus. Bah écoutez, l'Union
européenne compte dans ses rangs 28 pays
membres, donc il faut continuer à
chercher. Peut-être vous allez retrouver
quelqu'un. Euh
ouais, on va pas se faire que des amis
mais bon. Euh on commence tout de suite
dans le dur. L'affaire Skripal.
Oui, je suis prêt.
Je vous écoute.
Euh vous avez choisi le même ton que nos
partenaires britanniques.
Peut-être que vous pouvez préciser la
question.
Ce qui est intéressant en fait, c'est de
vous recevoir aujourd'hui parce que on
entend beaucoup de choses dans les
médias euh et on pense que la meilleure
chose, c'est de parler d'homme à homme
et et de se dire les choses, de poser
les cartes sur table. Les mots ont un
sens et enlever le sens au mot rajoute
de la misère au monde. Et j'aimerais
qu'on aborde les choses, franchement.
Franchement, non, je suis très content
d'aborder ce sujet parce que là, nous
avons tout notre temps pour pour en
parler. Euh ces derniers euh semaines,
j'ai été invité plusieurs fois aux
différents euh chaînes radio plutôt
différents radios et quelques chaînes de
télévision. C'est toujours 7 minutes, 8
minutes, donc c'est pas euh suffisant
pour aborder euh euh cet incident majeur
euh qui a déjà un impact assez important
pour les relations entre la Russie et
l'Occident collectif et qui aura
peut-être l'impact supplémentaire. Bon
euh l'incident s'est produit le 4 mars
de cette année.
L'ambassade de Russie en Grande-Bretagne
à Londres a contacté presque
immédiatement les autorités britanniques
pour obtenir les premières informations
parce que deux ressortissants russes, il
faut dire que à ma connaissance et la
fille de monsieur monsieur Scripal Julia
et lui-même monsieur Serge Scripal sont
toujours des citoyens russes. Donc pour
nous, c'est tout d'abord les citoyens
russes parce que quand une personne a
une double nationalité, selon la
pratique qui existe, nous le considérons
comme le citoyen de notre pays et notre
pays, Grande-Bretagne par exemple le
considère comme leur propre citoyens.
Mais en tout cas, selon les conventions
euh de la Vienne euh sur les affaires
consolaires euh et conformément au à un
accord bilatéral qui existe entre la
Gr-Bretagne euh et la Russie depuis
l'époque soviétique, on a voulu tout de
suite savoir des précisions, avoir
information plus ou moins détaillées.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Dans quel
état se trouvent ces gens-là, où sont où
se trouvent-ils ? Et voilà, nous avons
proposé dès le début et notre première
note a été envoyée au ministère des
affaires étrangèrre de la
Grande-Bretagne le 6 mars, c'estàdire
dans 2 jours après l'incident.
Euh on n' pas reçu de réponse
qu'on a déjà approfondi et même aucune
réponse, mais au contraire le le 12
mars, c'est-à-dire dans euh dans 8
jours, le premier ministre britannique
euh Non non non mars mars parce que euh
président Oui. 8 jours après, le 12
mars, le premier ministre britannique
Thesa May euh a déclaré
absolument officiellement plutôt il a
accusé la Russie d'être impliqué dans
cette affaire et la partie britannique
a posé ces questions comme la presse
occidentale présente ce que
ce que les Britanniques ont demandé à la
partie russe. Mais en réalité, il y
avait pas de question. Il y avait un
choix entre deux options. Soit vous
devez reconnaître votre implication de
cette affaire, votre responsabilité pour
cette attaque chimique. Soit vous de
reconnaître, toujours reconnaître que
vous avez perdu le contrôle euh sur les
arsenaux, sur les armes chimiques que
vous possédez. Donc les deux options euh
sont comme ça, sont absolument
négatives.
Aucune volonté d'essayer de coopérer,
aucune volonté d'essayer de réunir des
experts, de solliciter euh l'aide euh de
de l'organisation pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques qui se basent à la
haie. Juste des accusations enfondées
sans présenter aucune preuve, aucun
aucun détail de ce qui se produit à
Salberry. Ben évidemment euh les la
langue euh des ultomatomes, c'est pas la
langue qu'il faut utiliser en parlant
avec la Russie euh qui est en membre
responsable de la de la communauté
internationale et en membre responsable
de l'organisation h pour l'interdiction
des armes chimiques. Et là, je dois
vous dire que évidemment à l'époque
soviétique,
l'Union l'Union Soviétique, mon pays
comme plusieurs d'autres pays du monde
effectu des recherches approfondies dans
le domaine de la chimie militaire comme
nous disons, avait des arsénaux
chimiques, des armes chimiques non
négligeables, mais après l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique, après la
naissance de la nouvelle Russie
démocratique
Euh en 92, en 1992,
conformément au décret
présidentiel,
euh toutes les recherches dans le
domaine de la chimie militaire ont été
arrêté, stoppé définitivement. Nous
avons cessé de d'effectuer des
recherches dans ce domaine-là. Et euh un
peu plus tard, on a commencé un long
processus euh de de destruction des
armes chimiques qui était très
important. Notre arsenal compté, si je
me trompe pas, 40000 tonnes. On a euh
c'était vraiment une longue processus
qui a demandé beaucoup
d'investissements. On a effectué euh
cette destruction euh avec
le et surtout avec le concours euh des
pays occidentaux. On a construit des
usines spéciales avec la participation
des experts euh occidentaux, des des
spécialistes euh évidemment euh sous
contrôle euh des experts euh de
l'organisation pour l'interdiction
chimique. Et on a euh terminé c ce
travail euh en 2017. On a détruit
complètement nos arsenaux euh chimiques.
Évidemment en présence et euh sous
contrôle euh de l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques. Ce
qui a été euh noté, ce qui a été déclaré
officiellement, ça y est, la Russie ne
possède plus des armes chimiques.
Donc
dans ce contexte, ces accusations qui
sont arrivées comme ça euh sans aucune
même explication quelles seraient des
motivations crédibles
de la Fédération de Russie. Euh donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait dans cette
situation là, dans ces circonstances ?
Si je peux me permettre, elle a elle a
peut-être pensé que quand même Scripal,
qui est un agent euh un agent double qui
a balancé des des agents russes euh dans
le camp d'en face, elle s'est peut-être
dit quand même euh
les Russes, ils avaient peut-être décidé
de se le faire.
Oui. Bon oui. Euh les explications qui
ont été données ont été tirées des
romans de Jean Lecré. Euh là
vraiment euh je suis vous je vous je
suis reconnaissant de m'avoir donné de
m'avoir donné la possibilité d'expliquer
toute cette histoire dans les détails.
Donc monsieur Serge Scripal
était un officier euh des renseignements
militaires russes qui a commencé à
collaborer, si on peut le dire, avec les
services secrets britanniques
euh dans les années 90 et c'est
important. Il
s'est fait attraper comment ? Par
l'argent, par les femmes, par la
pression, par quoi ? Je connais pas les
détails mais c'est c'est vraiment c'est
du business, c'est pour les argent, pour
l'argent. Et là, c'est très important de
souligner que il a coopéré, il a
commencé à coopérer, à travailler pour
euh Secret Service euh après
l'effondrement avait après la
disparition de l'Union soviétique. Donc
vous comprenez que cit pas un acte
idéologique parce que je peux comprendre
quand on dit que les tops les doubles
agents de l'époque soviétique lut par
cette façon contre le régime totalitaire
comme Vladimir comme Vladimir Vetrof.
Euh oui. Bon euh
écoutez, en tout cas, je peux pas
exclure qu'il y a des officiers de de
des services de renseignement qui
voulaient par cette façon de changer
quelque chose, mais franchement, on dit
c'était toujours pour l'argent. C'était
toujours pour l'argent. Et au contraire
euh il y a des euh lors lors ce sont pas
des lords mais en tout cas il y a des
des grands officiers de renseignement
soviétique britannique les citoyens
britanniques, les britanniques qui ont
commencé à qui coopéraient avec les
renseignements soviétiques pour des
raisons purement idéologiques. C'était
leur choix moral idéologique. C'était
leur façon de lutter contre la menace
d'une guerre nucléaire entre deux blocs.
C'est leur choix idéologique parce que
ils pensaient que l'Union Soviétique
propose une autre version de vie, une
autre voix euh beaucoup plus juste,
beaucoup plus sociale et cetera. Tandis
que non non nos transfuge, nos top
trop souvent c'était pour l'argent.
Vladimir Vetrov, il a pas il a pas trahi
pour des questions de de d'argent ni des
d'idéologie. Il a trahi parce qu'il
trouvait que le Kremelin et le KGP
étaient corrompus.
Oui. D'accord. Il y a des cas qu'on crée
mais en tout cas c'est pas la c'est
Non non je veux dire que c'est pas si
important que ça.
Je suis je je ne veux pas accuser
Scripal, je veux pas le traiter comme un
traître, mais il faut que nous
comprenions que il était en traître, un
traître classique qui vendait les
secrets d'état juste pour l'argent parce
que
vous vous l'avez échangé
et euh pardon euh Skripal a été arrêté
par les il a été démasqué, il a été
arrêté par les services euh spéciaux
russes. Il y avait il y avait eu il y
avait eu une en tribunal
il a été accusé à 12 années de prison si
je me trompe pas. Il a passé 5 ans dans
la prison et après il a été il a été
gracié et après il a été échangé pour
agent euh russe. Euh c'était en échange
euh organisé par la Russie et les
États-Unis.
Donc voilà, euh
je peux dire que il a payé ses dettes,
il a été gracié et en plus il faut
ajouter que euh il ne faisait pas partie
euh de euh des services spéciaux russes
depuis mi-née 90. Il a quitté euh les
services très très Il a fait il y a un
très bon moment.
Euh après elle a passé plusieurs années
dans le prison, après elle a passé
plusieurs années en Grande-Bretagne en
toute sérénité.
Il a perdu les contacts avec euh les
milieux de renseignement russes depuis
des années déjà. Il ne représentait
aucun danger.
Nous ne sommes pas dupes
euh euh comment dirais-je patron
britannique, il l'a déjà dit. Euh
évidemment après euh après leur son euh
son arrivée en Grande-Bretagne, je pense
qu'il a contacté, il a été contacté, il
a travaillé avec les services
britanniques. Euh aucune idée qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit, qu'est-ce qu'il n'a pas
qu'est-ce qu'il n'a pas dit. Mais en
tout cas, ça y est, euh c'était
quelqu'un qui a quitté les services
russes il y a très longtemps. Il il ne
représentait aucun intérêt ni pour nous,
ni pour ni pour le Britannique à mon
avis. Alors, votre interprétation de la
réaction de Thesa
euh mais je reviens quand même à cette
histoire là parce que
je veux poser la question à tout le
monde, aux internautes. Euh chaque
action, chaque démarche, chaque attaque
euh doit avoir quelques doit doit euh
doit être effectué euh
pour quelques raisons.
Réfléchissez
quel profit, quel bénéfice Russie
pouvait pouvait-elle avoir en liquidant
ce double agent, ce top, ce traître, je
sais pas qui.
La victimisation.
Euh tout d'abord euh je vous rappelle
que euh l'attaque a été effectuée 2
semaines uniquement avant les élections
présidentielles en Russie et quelques
mois 3 ou 4 mois avant le début du
champignat du monde de football aussi
toujours en Russie. Mais quelle idée
peut pouvait euh expliquer euh cette
action, cette attaque ? Quel intérêt
Russie pouvait avoir en attaquant ce
scripal et sa fille ?
juste des problèmes parce que bon
évidemment une attaque avec
l'utilisation de l'arme chimique à la
veille des événements c'est important
mais vraiment pour nous c'est de la
folie c'est de la foutaise accuser nous
accuser pour cette attaque chimique euh
n'a aucun sens pour nous son quelles
sont vos hypothèses
n'a aucun sens pour nous
quelles sont vos hypothèses
euh c'est une provocation
très grossière
de qui
de qui ça c'est une bonne question mais
nous au lieu milieu de euh ou plutôt à
la différence avec nos partenaires
britanniques. Nous ne voulons pas et
nous ne pouvons pas accuser personne
parce que nous n'avons aucune
information sur ce qui s'est passé à
Solsbury. Euh qui je peux vous dire déjà
euh
en état hier.
Donc vous avez demandé qu'on vous
transmette des éléments des des éléments
témoins de la substance utilisée, chose
qu'on ne vous a pas remis. Euh pas
uniquement, nous avons demandé ou plutôt
nous avons proposé la coopération la
coopération technique, la coopération
entre des experts, des des la
coopération des professionnels, euh la
la coopération des experts à titre dans
le format bilatéral, dans le format
format multilatéral parce que tous les
deux, la Gr-Britagne et la Russie, nous
sommes membres de cette organisation
pour l'intervention des armes chimiques
qui prévoit plusieurs mécanismes.
euh
d'investigation, d'enquête communes ou
séparé, mais plusieurs formats. Si les
partenaires britanniques ne veulent pas
coopérer ou plutôt euh examiner cette
affaire, effectuer cette enquête à titre
billatéral avec la Russie, pas de
problème. Il y a l'organisation que peut
fournir son expertise. L'organisation
peut jouer un rôle dans médiateur.
L'organisation peut créer une
commission. Donc plusieurs formats sont
possibles, sont sur la table. La la
Grande-Bretagne n'a euh profité euh
d'aucune de ces formats. Il a juste
accusé la Russie sans présenter, je
répète, aucun détail, aucun photo,
aucune preuve, pas d'information
concrète, rien du tout. Qu'est-ce que
nous savons sur ce qui s'est passé à
Salbury ? Nous savons que en policier a
retrouvé ce couple père et fille scripal
dans un jardin dans un parcanique
à Solsbury dans un état déjà très
mauvais. il a été contaminé à son tour.
On a évoqué que plusieurs bon une deux
dizaines de personnes ont été touchées
par cette affaire-là, mais nous n'avons
aucune information sur d'autres euh
victimes de cette drame. Nous savons que
le policier a été hospitalisé mais euh
sa vie n'était pas en danger et nous
savons que deux personnes se trouvent
dans le dans l'état de comma.
Nous ne savons pas, il paraît-il que euh
ils sont tombés dans cet état après la
visite d'un restaurant dans Pizzeraia
euh à Solsbury. Euh voilà ce qu'on
savait au moment de cette attaque.
Après, les différents rumeurs ont
commencé à tomber ici et là. Les
différents euh
journaux britanniques proposit toujours
une nouvelle version de contamination.
On dit par exemple que c'est la poignée
de la porte d'entrée dans le apportement
qui a été euh touchée par
cette substance, par cet agent en chimie
qu'on appelle le Novitch.
Novitchok, ce sont les Britanniques qui
appellent ça Novitchok. Là, en passant,
je peux vous dire que euh selon les
déclarations officielles euh de la
partie russe, euh la substance avec un
tel nom n'a jamais été ni euh euh
produit ni stockée en Fédération de
Russie.
Donc voilà, euh en je continue de parler
de ces premiers jours après euh cet
incident. Euh après l'accusation
officielle qui a été euh rendue publique
par Thesa Meille, nous avons sollicité
l'organisation pour l'interes pubiques.
Nous avons proposé leur médiation plutôt
nous avons demandé aux Britanniques de
s'adresser à cette organisation. Nous
avons à main entreprise, on a envoyé
quatre notes euh
au ministère britannique des affaires
étrangères en proposant euh les
différentes façons d'agir et tout et
surtout en manifestant notre volonté,
notre ouverture, notre disponibilité
pour la coopération.
Pas de réponse euh solide, euh pas de
volonté d'agir ensemble, juste des
occusations, je répète, sans aucun
fondement. Et jusqu'aujourd'hui, on a
reçu rien. Pas de photos, pas de euh
pas des conversations téléphoniques
déchiffrées, pas de euh d'images des
caméras et vous savez qu'en Bretagne les
caméras sont partout. Donc il y a
plusieurs euh voies pour effectuer
l'enquête. Toujours aucune information.
Mais du coup, nous voyons, nous savons
aujourd'hui que euh leur état de santé
de Sergier Screpal, de Julia Screpal
s'améliore de façon très nette, très
spectaculaire, surtout de Julia, mais
paril que la vie de Scripal lui-même
n'est pas en danger désormais.
Quelles sont vos sources ?
Ah, c'est toujours les mass médias
évidemment, toujours les masses médias
mais maintenant c'est c'est
une formation confirmée que Yuli Skipal
se sent bien parce qu'il y a déjà ses
paroles elle qu'elle souhaiterait
retourner le plus vite possible en
Russie. D'après Spoutnik, un article
d'aujourd'hui ou d'hier.
Je peux pas vous confirmer ça, je mais
je sais que euh ses parents euh ont déjà
déposé la dément Visa à l'ambassade
britannique à Moscou pour aller
rejoindre Julia. Julia, elle a demandé
de ne pas trop euh déranger de ne pas la
déranger en ce moment de convalescence.
Euh mais elle est vivante, elle est bien
vivante et vraiment elle se sent
beaucoup mieux. et lui Serg Scrpal
aussi. Et là, je reviens à à l'opinion
au disons aux paroles des spécialistes,
des experts soviétiques qui ont quitté
l'Union soviétique ou plutôt qui ont
quitté la Russie après
que le rideau de fer est tombé. Ils se
sont retrouvés à l'étranger où ils ont
coopéré beaucoup avec les séries
spéciaux et les structures d'état des de
la Grande-Bretagne, des États-Unis et
d'autres pays européens toujours en
proposant leur expertise dans le domaine
où il était des spécialistes et
c'est-à-dire la chimie militaire. Voilà
pourquoi nous disons que accuser la
Russie n'a aucun sens parce que la
formule
est connue, la formule a été publiée.
Les experts russes avec tous leurs
connaissances, avec certaines
documentations sont partis
en à l'Occident absolument sans aucun
problème parce que ça y est, c'était pas
des des tops, c'était pas des
transfuges, c'était juste des chercheurs
qui ont quitté la Russie et qui se sont
installés soit aux États-Unis, soit euh
en Grande-Bretagne, dans d'autres pays
du monde et qui ont coopéré beaucoup
avec euh disons les structures d'état
intéressées.
euh d'apprendre plus sur leur travail et
cetera. Donc selon leurs opinions, si on
utilise un agent chimique militaire
de ce type-là,
il y a pas de vivant et au contraire,
les victimes être beaucoup plus nombreux
que ces couples euh de scripal. Et
aujourd'hui, nous voyons que leur état
s'améliore. Donc encore une fois, une
question se pose. C'était quoi comme
argent chimique ? Qu'est-ce que c'était
? Si c'était Novitch,
c'est les choses qui prennent
aujourd'hui une tournure très positive
témoignent que il s'agit plutôt d'un
agent chimique différent que Nachuc.
Bon,
ça chauffe un peu. Il y a des sanctions.
On vous a désigné encore comme une bête
à corne, c'est encore la faute des
Russes. Vous le prenez comment ? Vous
allez réagir comment ? Euh quand vous
voyez euh l'Europe faciliter
l'acheminement de troupes à travers le
territoire européen euh jusqu'à votre
frontière, quand on avait proposé à la
Suède de venir discuter, c'est parce que
on avait vu que la Suède réimprimait un
petit un petit fasicule pour prévenir sa
population d'une guerre contre la
Russie.
Vous réagissez comment ? On voit vos
sous-marins en mer noire se balader.
On voit des photos dans nos réseaux nous
remonter aux oreilles avec vos
sous-marins qui se baladent. On voit des
drones américains ou autanesque se
balader près de chez vous.
C'est la guerre là ? Non, c'est la
guerre froide à la papa.
Euh non. Bon, en tout cas, nous voulons
éviter de considérer l'état des choses
comme la guerre froide parce que la
guerre froide, c'est quelque chose qui
appartient pleinement à l'époque de la
confrontation entre deux camps
idéologiquement opposés. Euh j'espère
que nous ne sommes pas euh dans l'état
d'une guerre froide, mais euh nous nous
parlons plutôt de la détrioration
ultérieure des relations entre
l'Occident collective et la Russie. Euh
les sanctions, voilà. Euh tout d'abord,
évidemment, nous avons exprimé tout de
suite notre protestation très ferme
après les nouvelles sanctions, les
décisions de certains pays membres de
l'Union européenne, mais pas pas tous,
pas tous. Euh ce qui est important euh
une moitié des pays euh membres de
l'Union européenne ont choisi cette
option euh de l'expulsion des diplomates
russes.
Vous avez vous avez envoyé une dizaine
de questions euh à vos homologues du
Kedorse ?
Tout à fait. et nous avons envoyé nos
questions à nos homologues britanniques,
à nos homologues français et aux bon et
à l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques. Mais nous n'avons pas
reçu de réponses. Euh
la substance de la substance de vos
questions, c'était quoi ? Ce sont des
questions purement techniques. Aucune
pro background, aucune idéologie. Les
questions purement techniques. Si vous
participez dans l'enquête technique,
sur laquelle base juridique euh
qu'est-ce que vous ont présenté les
partenaires britanniques comme
témoignage, comme preuve ? Euh selon
quel article de du statut de
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
charges chimiques les experts de
l'organisation sont partis pour la
Grande-Bretagne ? Est-ce que vous vous
avez des des échantillons de cet agent
chimique qui a été utilisé ? Quelle est
votre expertise dans ce domaine là ?
Est-ce que vous avez effectué des
recherches dans ce domaineelà ? Ce sont
des questions très techniques et euh
pour nous tout à fait légitime et
logique, surtout quand on nous accuse
d'une crime aussi odieuse. Mais je
répète, on n'a pas reçu de réponse.
Mais en revenant à notre réaction, à ce
qui s'est passé, nous avons exprimé
notre protestation mais à la fois
notre déception parce que franchement
nous étions très déçus par cette
réaction dictée par la solidarité
euroatlantique.
En tout cas, c'est comme ça que euh nos
partenaires euh occidentaux euh
imaginent la solidarité. suivre
euh un pays membre de l'Union européenne
sans demander des preuves, sans avoir
tout ce qui l'image de tout ce qui s'est
passé. On nous dit que on nous a
présenté des preuves convaincants, qui
nous ont convaincu que euh
il y a pas d'autres explications
plausibles. Voilà la formule qui a été
choisie et c'est une seule formule qui a
guidé les pays membres de l'Union
européenne dans leur décision, dans leur
communiqué comment
et d'expulsion de diplomates
et d'expulsion de diplomates. Il n'y a
pas d'autres explications plausibles.
Combien combien il y en a eu d'expulsés
dans le monde ? combien en France et qui
c'était et quel poste à quel poste ils
œuvra dans l'ambassade ? Euh combien
paraît-il euh dans tout le monde à peu
près 150 à ma connaissance euh nos nos
mesures de rétorsion ont été euh
symétriques, absolument symétriques. En
ce qui concerne la France, quatre
diplomates euh euh ont été expulsés et
quatre diplomates français ont ont été
expulsés également. Mais je peux pas
commenter euh leur poste et leur
positionnement au sein de notre de nos
structure diplomatique en France.
Il était au secrétariat, ils étaient
quoi ? Ils s'occupaient des espaces
verts. Comprenez-vous ? Euh je peux pas
commenter euh cette information. Je peux
pas commenter voilà cet aspect-là. Euh
vous savez, il y a des coutumes, il y a
des coutumes diplomatiques, il y a des
mais on ne parle pas. Il faut poser la
question au qu d'ors liser les journaux.
C'est le qu d'ors qui les a choisis ou
c'est vous qui les avez choisi ?
Non, évidemment euh chaque fois c'est
euh c'est la partie qui prenne qui prend
la décision d'expulser les diplomates.
C'est elle qui nous donne les noms des
diplomates qui doivent partir, qui
doivent quitter le territoire national.
Est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
l'Occident a cherché à vous faire perdre
la face ?
Euh l'Occident euh globalement dit, je
sais pas si on peut euh dire comme ça
parce que l'Occident est différent.
L'Occident n'est pas homogène. Il y a la
Pologne et il y a la Grèce. Il y a la
Grande-Bretagne et il y a le Chypre. Il
y a la Suède et il y a la Slovénie. Il y
a la France et il y a l'Estonie. Chaque
fois, chaque pays est différent. Chaque
pays euh a une position nuancée comment
se homme a suivi comme un seul homme sur
ce coup-là. Euh oui, mais je répète,
nous comprenons que c'est le principe de
la solidarité européenne et
transatlantique. Voilà les les règles de
jeu qui sont respectées. Mais vous voyez
que comme je vous ai comme je vous ai
déjà dit, 14 pays membres de l'Union
européenne on ont expulsé les diplomates
russes. Euh peut-être 16 aujourd'hui,
mais en tout cas presque la moitié. Euh,
on préférait de ne pas prendre des
mesures euh pareilles. Ils ont euh non,
les paraît-il les Tqus ont expulsé un ou
ou deux diplomates. En plus, chaque pays
a expulsé une nombre différent de
diplomates. Plusieurs pays ont expulsé
un seul diplomate. Mais euh c'est pas
grave ou plutôt c'est pas grave, ça n'a
aucune différence. Euh l'expulsion,
c'est déjà une expulsion, peu importe
quel nombre, mais il y a des pays qui
n'ont pas pris cette décision et euh ces
pays sont nombreux, ces pays qui ont
préféré quand même euh de ne pas se
dépêcher d'attendre les résultats. Et je
répète toujours que euh la formule a été
bien choisie, pas d'explication
plausible,
sauf la responsabilité de la Russie.
Pour nous, c'est tout à fait ridicule.
C'est pas sérieux.
Donald Trump a proposé de réintégrer
des diplomates dans l'ambassade.
Est-ce que vous avez décidé de de faire
la même chose ?
Mais c'est tout à fait normal. C'est
c'est normal pour la pratique
diplomatique. L'expulsion
des diplomates ne signifie pas que les
postes sont fermés, sont annulés. Non,
dans quelques temps ce peuvent ce poste
peuvent être occupés par d'autres
diplomates qui viendront dans quelques
temps. Donc et
bon, on va se parler franchement. OK.
Essayons.
Est-ce que la la pilule vous reste en
travers de la gorge ? Est-ce que
derrière quand Vladimir Poutine montre
le nouvel arsenal russe et les nouvelles
capacités russes d'interception et de
frappe à la télé en grande pompe avec
renfort d'imag ? Est-ce que c'est un
signe que la pilule cette fois-ci ne
passe pas ?
Euh écoutez
une pilule.
Euh je dois vous dire que c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour la première fois que la
Russie est l'objet d'une attaque
organisée euh euh de la part des pays
occidentaux.
La dernière remonte à quoi et c'était
laquelle ? H écoutez, je pense des
sanctions après la crise en Ukraine. Les
sanctions qui ont été beaucoup plus
important que l'expulsion de quelques
dizaines voire en centaines
150 diplomates russes. Je peux vous dire
que nous restons nous tenons bon, nous
restons debout euh nous allons surmonter
ça. En tout cas, nous sommes persuadés
que cette aggravation supplémentaire des
relations entre l'Occident et la Russie
ne correspond pas aux intérêts profonds
de de l'Occident et de la Russie. Nous
avons vraiment
euh plusieurs choses à faire ensemble.
Voilà pourquoi notre déception. au lieu
de lutter contre par exemple le
terrorisme international et la France a
été frappée il y a quelques jours on
vaevenir
par les terroristes par en terroristes
euh encore une fois euh nous voulons
nous nous aspirons à
expliquer à nos partenaires occidentaux
que la menace ne vient pas de la Russie.
C'est pas la Russie qui qui représente
en vrai danger au monde occidental. Nous
faisons partie de votre monde parce que
la Russie aujourd'hui c'est un pays euh
qui a déjà construit un capitalisme très
libéral, je dirais un peu même sauvage.
Vous parlez de capitalisme
qui a été pris de l'Occident. Nous
faisons partie de la même civilisation
culturellement et euh moralement.
Vous parlez de capitalisme aujourd'hui,
il y a eu des sanctions et les marchés
financiers russes
se pour parler trivalement se sont
cassés la gueule à plus de 10 %. Est-ce
que les sanctions économiques,
c'est-à-dire les futurs chômeurs que ça
va créer en en Russie, est-ce que les
chômeurs coûtent plus cher que les morts
? Euh vous avez euh chaque euh médaille
a deux euh faces et euh je peux vous
rassurer que euh évidemment les
sanctions ne nous facilite pas la vie,
mais sachez que les sanctions ont frappé
nos nos sanctions euh comment dire-je
euh nos mesures de rétorsion euh à
l'encontre des pays occidentaux ont
coûté beaucoup euh aux économies des
pays membres de l'Union européenne. Et
vous les Français, vous devez les vous
devez les savoir surtout dans le domaine
d'agriculture. Donc oui, les sanctions
ne nous facilitent pas la vie, nous
compliquent la vie, surtout dans le
domaine financier évidemment, mais on se
débrouille relativement bien et notre
notre économie euh connaît la croissance
aujourd'hui 1,5 %, c'est pas beaucoup
évidemment,
c'est toujours plus que nous, non ? Bon,
en tout cas comparable mais il faut dire
que nous étions beaucoup nous étions
nous étions frappés beaucoup plus
sérieusement par la baisse des prix pour
les hydrocarbures. Et là, nous avons
beaucoup de problèmes avec ces
hydrocarbures parce que d'un côté c'est
une manne, de l'autre côté c'est un peu
comme de la drogue. Euh il faut
développer l'économie, il faut
diversifier l'économie. Et euh vous avez
euh mentionné euh les nouveaux armements
qui ont été élaborés euh en Russie et
présentés par notre président euh lors
de son allocution devant le parlement du
pays et devant tout le monde. Il a
beaucoup parlé des des armements et bon
c'est tout à fait compr, c'est logique,
c'est en signal et cetera.
C'est un secret de polinel. s'est
adressé aussi bien euh à au à la
population russe que aux élites euh euh
du monde entier et surtout de
l'Occident. Mais peut-être vous n'avez
pas remarqué les paroles beaucoup plus
importants du président qui euh ont été
prononcées pendant la première partie de
son discours. Il a dit clairement qui
est notre ennemi numéro 1 ? C'est pas
l'Occident, c'est pas les États-Unis,
c'est pas la Grande-Bretagne et bien sûr
c'est pas la France. C'est notre rétard
économique et technologique et
scientifique. Ça c'est notre problème,
le rétardement, le rétard. Et c'est là
où nous voulons concentrer tous nos
efforts. Nous ne voulons pas entrer en
nouvelle course aux armements. Euh la
dernière course aux armements nous a
coûté beaucoup, y compris notre pays, en
tout cas parmi d'autres facteurs. Donc
nous avons aucun intérêt d'entrer en
confrontation euh avec l'Occident,
confrontation idéologique, politique,
euh militaire, aucun intérêt. Nous avons
une tâche beaucoup plus importante,
moderniser notre économie. préparer euh
le pays, la population aux nouveaux
défis euh qui euh naissent aujourd'hui
et demain, qui vont apparaître bientôt,
les défis technologiques, euh les défis
intellectuels et notre tardement qui est
qui est connu, c'est pas un secret et
nous parlons ouvertement de ce
retardement. Ça c'est notre ennemi
numéro 1 et c'est là où nous voulons
concentrer tous nos efforts. Évidemment,
sans oublier nos intérêts nationaux,
sans sans oublier la nécessité de
maintenir euh disons nos capacités
militaires en haut niveau élevé. Mais
même si on parle de ces efforts
militaires, je vous rappelle que le
budget militaire de la Russie, c'est 70
milliards d'euros plutôt de dollars et
le budget euh des États-Unis, c'est 700
euh milliards de dollars. Donc
imaginez-vous, est-ce que la Russie peut
représenter un réel danger à qui que ce
soit ? Bah, ça peut représenter un réel
danger quand on voit que les missiles
patriotes ne fonctionnent pas, hein. Et
quand on voit les missiles S400
fonctionner,
ben écoutez, espérons espérons que nous
nous euh nous ne verrons pas comment ça
fonctionne les complexes S400. On le
voit en Syrie.
Il faut mieux éviter ça. Il faut mie
Syrie. Comment ça se passe en Syrie ? En
série, la situation a beaucoup évolué
depuis même notre dernière rencontre ici
chez vous parce que
vous voyez que euh malgré tout, malgré
euh la goutentale, malgré les
accrochages ici et là,
quand vous parlez de la goutta, vous
parlez de la frappe du moins ce qui est
annoncé comme une frappe chimique sur
une enclave au nord de Damas qui aurait
été perpétu.
Nous pouvons revenir à ce sujet
spécialement. Je parle plutôt de la
situation globale parce que Gouta
oriental, c'était euh le point de
tension le plus important euh pendant
quelques semaines déjà, pendant quelques
mois. Mais euh malgré tout ça, euh la
situation en Syrie aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus stable que il y a 2 3 ans.
Euh le niveau de violence a baissé
beaucoup. Euh les zones de déescalade
existent et fonctionnent globalement
bien. Et si je reviens à la goutt
orientale, je rappelle que euh cette
région contrôlée par l'opposition
islamique, y compris par les gens de
Japratan Nusra, reconnu comme
organisation théoriste par le NU. cette
région adjacente à la capitale syrienne,
c'est un vraiment euh euh source de
tension euh pour toute la Syrie et pour
euh la capitale euh de la Syrie Damas.
Pourquoi l'armée syrienne a commencé une
une opération contreiste dans la Gouta
orientale ? parce que en novembre
2017, c'est-à-dire l'année dernière, les
groupes armés très puissants dans cette
région là ont effectué des attaques
organisées, une grande offensive contre
les positions de l'armée syrienne près
de Damas et ne cessit pas d'effectuer
des tirs de requê d'altie lourde contre
la capitale contre la capitale syrienne.
Là, je peux vous confirmer parce que
notre ambassade se trouve dans la zone
qui tombe toujours sous les comment qui
qui est qui qui est joignable par les
euh par les moyens qui possèdent les
rebelles ou plutôt très souvent des
terroristes dans la gouttare orientale.
Finalement, la décision a été prise de
nettoyer cette zone des des des forces
qui torpie les tentatives de paix
effectué par la Russie, par la Turquie,
par l'Iran et soutenu par le
gouvernement syrien. C'est ça a été
nettoyé euh au chlore. Euh euh je peux
dire que c'était pas nettoyé parce que
vous savez que c'était le résultat euh
des négociations.
La grande partie de ces zones ont tombé
dans les mains de l'armée syrienne après
le départ organisé
euh des
des des comment des
rebelles, des euh des membres de
différentes organisations euh islamistes
qui opéraient dans cette zone-là.
C'était un départ organisé, bien encadré
euh par les médiateurs russes. Ils sont
partis sans déposer les armes. Ils sont
partis avec leurs armes à Idlip.
Et euh mais évidemment euh ces décisions
ces décisions ont été ces décisions ont
été prises après l'offensive euh de
l'armée syrienne et un couill de succès.
Votre votre interprétation euh du
massacre d'hier
massacre. Je je pense je pense que nous
pouvons parler d'une nouvelle euh d'une
nouvelle provocation. Et je peux vous
expliquer pourquoi je le dis, mais
expliquez-moi pourquoi le régime sérien
qui contrôle déjà toute la région, qui a
presque réglé le problème de gouttard
oriental qui ne connaît pas de problème
avec la euh la la pénétration dans les
zones tenues par quelques groupements de
rebelles qui restent encore là-bas.
Pourquoi utiliser de façon très ciblée
quelques disons genent ou plutôt
quelques munition munie des armes
chimiques ? À quoi bon ? Pourquoi ? Pour
faire quoi ? C'est déjà l'affaire est
déjà presque réglée. Euh plusieurs
dizaines de milliers des rebelles avec
leur familles sont partis euh à Edlip,
les autres sont partis dans d'autres
régions.
Pourquoi bon utiliser l'arme chimique ?
que vous avez émis l'hypothèse que
l'armée de Bachar et Assad ait frappé
l'enclave et que une de leurs bombes
soit tombé sur un stock de chlore détenu
par la partie adverse.
Ce n'est pas exclu. Ce n'est pas exp ce
n'est pas exclu. C'est un peu c'est une
répétition euh de ce qui s'est passé à
Hanikhoun. euh une seule bombe qui est
tombée avec euh des éléments chimiques,
avec des agents chimiques. Aucune
explication logique. Et tout ça au
moment où tous les leaders occidentaux,
pas tous les leaders mais en tout cas
les Américains et les Français disent
que c'est la ligne rouge. L'utilisation
des armes chimiques, c'est la ligne
rouge. Est-ce que vous pensez que Bachar
Al-Assad veut euh, comment dire-je,
provoquer euh les puissances occidentaux
occidentales euh
pour euh de nouvelles attaques contre
son régime, contre son armée déjà très
affaiblie par ces temps de guerre. À
quoi bon ? Est-ce qu'il vous pouvez me
dire que peut-être il veut provoquer un
grand conflit entre les superpuissances
? Mais quel intérêt ? La première
victime, ce sera la Syrie et son
population. Donc pour moi, vous savez,
je peux comprendre quand une partie dans
un conflit fratricie, dans un conflit
armé utilise les gens chimiques, les
armes chimiques au moment où la
situation vraiment est très dangereuse.
Il faut sauver euh soi-même, il faut
arrêter l'offensive des ennemis. Là,
vous utilisez l'arme chimique. Mais au
moment de la victoire ou plutôt bon
victoire relative, nous répétons
toujours que le problème syrien ne
connaît pas la solution militaire. Mais
au moment où vous reprenez les
territoires, où vous vous sentez très
bien, vous vous sentez euh en force, en
position de force, à quoi bon utiliser
l'armement chimique tout en comprenant
que la réaction des certains de vos
ennemis pourraient être très très dure.
C'est pas logique.
Quel son quels sont vos ennemis ?
Quel que vous parlez de réaction de vos
ennemis ?
Non, je me mets à la place de Bachar
Al-Assad. Je ne parle pas de la Russie.
Je me mets à la place de l'assad qui est
l'ennemi de de Barchar Alassad. Je sais
pas, les États-Unis, la France, l'Arabie
Saoudite, les gens qui veulent son
départ.
Israël
Israël a occupé a toujours occupé une
position plutôt euh comment disais-je
modérée dans ce conflit. Il
une position une position modérée du
type quand quand Israël attaque
l'aéroport militaire dans la province de
Holmes.
Mais en tout cas pour l'instant c'est
pas encore confirmé. Euh non,
présentation d'innocence. D'accord.
Non non, je sais pas, c'est c'est fort
probable mais c'est pas encore confirmé.
En tout cas, ce qui est confirmé, c'est
que Israël a frappé plusieurs fois euh
les cibles sur les territoires syriens.
Et quand même et quand même je ne peux
que répéter que pendant ce conflit,
Israël occupait plutôt une position
neutre. Il ne réclama pas le départ de
Bachar Al-Assad. il ne il ne il ne
s'impliquait pas trop dans les affaires
syriennes. Ce qui veut Israël, c'est
assurer son propre sécurité. Les euh
dans la région euh dans la région des
Golan euh il des Golan. Oui, il voulait
vraiment assurer son sécurité et pour ce
qui est important pour Israël, c'est le
facteur iranien. Euh sur les
J'ai une question à vous poser. Euh le
système d'armement anti-aérien que vous
avez vendu euh à Bachar ElAssad
euh si mes souvenirs sont bon descendu
un un avion israélien. Est-ce que Est-ce
que est-ce qu'ils ont touché l'avion
israélien qui est tombé sur le
territoire israélien ?
Non, ça s'appelle descendre.
Oui. Oui. En tout cas, oui, mais c'était
le résultat du travail euh des des des
forces euh antiérien de
d'accord.
de la série.
Est-ce que vous pouvez pas paramétrer
votre système d'armement pour éviter ou
du moins est-ce que vous avez un
dialogue avec Israël pour éviter que les
l'espace aérien leur soit fermé ou c'est
une une volonté de votre part ?
Écoutez, nous avons des des relations
très solides et très constructives avec
Israël. Nous savons les préoccupations
sécuritaires d'Israël. Nous mantenons en
dialogue permanent. le premier ministre
israélien vient à Mouscou vraiment deux
fois par an, même peut-être plus
souvent. Euh les services de sont en
contact, les militaires sont en contact,
mais euh mais euh Israël euh entreprend
certaines actions et euh nous n'avons
aucun intérêt d'entrer en confrontation
avec Israël. Mais nous essayons à
expliquer à Israël, à la Turquie, aux
États-Unis que ce n'est pas dans
l'enterrêté de la région l'aggravation
militaire euh et des nouvelles tensions.
Quand les Turcs par exemple ont commencé
leur
offensif dans le nord de la Syrie, nous
avons compris les raisons de leur
inquiétude parce qu'ils pensent Oui, ils
son ils pensent à leur sécurité
nationale, ils pensent à leur intégrité
territoriale. Nous pouvons comprendre,
on va revenir sur la Turquie. Mais on
parle toujours quand même, je termine,
on parle toujours à nos amis turcs, à
nos partenaires turcs que il faut on
moment donné, il faut s'arrêter, il faut
pas aller très loin, sinon c'est une
grande aggravation euh de la situation
en série supplémentaire. les les avions
israéliens et les et les systèmes S400,
euh est-ce que le on peut paramétrer les
S400 pour reconnaître les transpondeurs
des avions euh militaire isra ?
Paramètra euh paramétrer, qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire régler pour éviter que les
missiles partent s'armer sur un avion
qui n'est pas censé se faire descendre.
Écoutez, là nous entrons dans les
détails trop techniques et militaires.
Est-ce que c'est un c'est un signal que
vous envoyez à Israël en disant voilà là
où les S700, les S400 sont positionnés,
personne ne rentre.
Euh écoutez, vous devez comprendre que
S400 et tous les autres moyens des CA
que nous avons en Syrie sont là pour
protéger les installations militaires
russes. Ils sont là pour protéger tous
nos bases militaires où où se où se
trouvent nos avions, où se trouvent nos
bateaux. C'est là leur tâche. Pour
l'instant, nous nous ne pouvons pas
assurer la sécurité totale euh de la
Syrie. Nous protégeons
nos sites mais nous avons déjà envoyé un
signal très fort à nos partenaires
américains en leur disant que si les
États-Unis vont frapper Damas, si euh la
vie de nos militaires et ils sont je
peux pas vous dire qu'ils sont partout
parce que notre contingent il est très
limité mais
quelques milliers mais il y a des
conseillers militaires qui sont dans les
États-majors ici et là Nous avons bien
expliqué que si la vie de nos militaires
soit mise en danger, nous allons réagir
de façon très très ferme. Nous allons
abattre non seulement les missiles mais
les porteurs de ces missiles. Le signal
a été bien envoyé.
Avec Israël, c'est un peu différent
parce que Israël n'a pas de vocation de
faire tomber le régime et là ses propres
enterrés. Euh oui, il a frappé. Nous ne
sommes pas très heureux de ces frappes
parce que tout ça déstabilise
déstabilise davantage la situation. Euh
mais en tout cas avec Israël, on ne
parle pas comme ça. Et en plus, je
répète, tout le monde sait où se
trouvent nos moyens et tout le monde
comprend que faut pas même penser à
attaquer les sites militaires russes,
proprement dit en Syrie.
Vous avez vendu de l'armement à la
Turquie
et la Turquie achète aussi du côté
occidental. Vous interprétez comment ce
double jeu au niveau de l'armement de la
Turquie ?
Euh écoutez, c'est de la commerce
surtout. Je vous rappelle que
on jour, on a signé avec la France un
contrat très important sur la vente de
deux euh
deux bâtiments de projection de de force
d'hélicoptère.
Oui. Bon, ils ont ce sont deux bâtiments
multifonctionnels y compris pour pour
porter des hélicoptères de type mistral.
Et euh à l'époque, c'était vraiment euh
un vrai percet euh un vrai témoignage
que les temps sont changés. La Russie
achète à pays membre de l'ETAN en
matériel militaire si important tandis
que la Russie c'est un très grand
producteur des armements, n'est-ce pas ?
Donc et la France c'était un pays c'est
c'est c'était aussi une une chose
absolument inédite pour la première
fois. en pays membre de le temps se
propose de vendre de produire et après
vendre des trucs si importants que de
deux bateau euh de type de mistral. Euh
donc c'était vraiment c'était un un vrai
événement qui a beaucoup euh comment
disais-je chagriné certains des
partenaires occidentaux de la France.
Euh le président Sarkozy, le président
de l'époque euh était sous pression
assez forte de deux côtés, du côté
américain et du côté de certains de ses
alliés euh européens et quand même, il a
pris cette décision. Donc voilà. Euh
c'est-à-dire
ils sont où ces bateaux maintenant ?
Euh c'est c'est l'Égypte qui les a
acheté et c'était le résultat des
tractations à trois. On a établi
ensemble avec la France, la Russie et
l'Égypte. Nous avons choisi cette
option, la France sous certains euh
conditions parce que il y avait des
technologies russe utilisé déjà euh sur
ces bateaux-là. Euh donc c'est l'Égypte
qui a acheté ces bateaux. Et là vous
devez poser plutôt la question à mon
collègue égyptien ou à mes collègues
égyptiens parce que
où sont-ils ces deux bâtiments ? Mais en
tout cas, Égypte, c'est un grand pays
euh arabe euh qui a aussi euh euh ses
propres intérêts et ses propres
nécessité de protection euh de ses
intérêts. Voilà. Donc en revenant à la
Turquie, euh
c'est pas une h une une affaire
extraordinaire. Il paraît que certains
pays membres de l'Étan déjà acheté
quelques matériel militaires chez la
Russie. si je trompe pas, il s'agit de
de la Grèce et du Chypre, mais euh le
contexte euh actuel évidemment rend
cette décision turque euh plutôt attire
l'enterrêt à à cette décision euh
turque. Mais qu'est-ce que je peux vous
dire ? Euh la Turquie ne se trouve ne se
trouve pas sous les sanctions de l'ONU.
Euh c'est une affaire euh russe-turque.
Euh la Turquie a voulu euh acquérir ses
moyens militaires. La Russie a a a donné
euh son accord à cette acquisition.
C'est dans l'intérêt de la Turquie et de
la Russie.
La la Turquie à vos yeux est un pays
suffisamment stable pour entreprendre
des négociations au niveau d'une
construction de centrale nucléaire.
Euh écoutez, la tentative de coup d'état
en Turquie a bien démontré que la
population euh soutient euh les
autorités légitimes, légitimement élues
euh de la Turquie et que ces autorités
contrôlent suffisamment bien la
situation pour écraser la tentative d'un
coup d'état militaire. Donc pour nous
euh la Turquie c'est un pays stable euh
acteur important dans la région euh
acteur important sur la scène
internationale avec laquelle nous avons
une longue histoire des relations euh et
beaucoup d'intérêt commun.
Ce coup d'état vos yeux il a été
faumenté par qui ? Oh euh non, c'est une
question à laquelle je peux pas vous
donner la réponse euh très concrète.
Nous savons très bien euh
quelle est la position d'Ankara,
euh quel sont les accusations d'Ankara
qui sont
euh c'est Abdouah Gul Gulem euh ce euh
dissident
dissident dissident turc qui selon les
informations euh des autorités turques
étaient à l'origine de cette tentative
de coup d'état. Mais je pense que comme
dans chaque pays euh il y a différents
courants, il y a différents euh pensées,
école de pensée euh
rien à dire. Cette tentative euh a
échoué et aujourd'hui la Turquie est
considérée toujours comme un pays
démocratique où le président où le
président est élu de façon absolument
démocratique.
Oui. J'ai parlé à mes collègues turcs,
ils reconnaissent que après le coup
d'état, le moment était très difficile
et les autorités ont été obligées de
prendre quelques mesures assez dures
pour prendre la la situation sous leur
contrôle absolu. Mais maintenant, la
situation s'améliore et je pense que la
sérénité va revenir.
Je je parle de ces aspects vraiment
intérieurs de la Turquie. Mais écoutez,
je suis je suis là pas pour euh
m'engérer dans les affaires turques ou
françaises. C'est à eux de euh résoudre
euh tout le problème euh de leur pays.
Est-ce que à votre avis la Turquie euh
cherche l'arme nucléaire ?
Non, pas du tout. Pas du tout. Euh la
Turquie euh c'est un membre responsable
de la communauté internationale. À ma
connaissance, les membres euh de la
traité euh sur la nonprolifération des
armes nucléaires et nous n'avons euh
aucune raison de soupçonner la Turquie
de voir quelques idées dans ce
contexte-elà.
On se penche un peu sur l'Iran. Quel
Quel rapport vous entretenez avec l'Iran
? Iran c'est un partenaire euh parfois
compliqué parce que Iran c'est un grand
pays régional qui veut jouer une rôle
grandissante dans la région. nous le
voyons, nous le constatons, mais euh
c'est un pays qui euh quand même
représente euh les intérêts euh d'une
euh d'un courant très important dans
l'islam, des chiites et c'est inévitable
pour nous que il entretient des
relations privilégiées avec les pays où
la minorité ou majorité chiite est très
important. Pour nous, c'est normal. Nous
ne voyons pas que l'Iran veut
déstabiliser
la région. Au contraire, nous pensons
que euh son rôle en Syrie était très
important pour arrêter la menace du
gadiste
avec le Esbola.
Esbola euh Hbola c'est une partie
politique libanais dont les
représentants siègent au Parlement.
C'est c'est c'est un c'est un parti
politique légitime
soutenu par l'Iran. Soutenu par l'Iran,
oui, il y a des liens traditionnels
parce que il y a des forces euh au banan
qui sont qui ont été toujours soutenues
par Damas, par la Syrie et il y a
d'autres forces politiques qui ont été
toujours soutenu par l'Occident, par la
France notamment. Bon, c'est normal, le
Liban, c'est un pays très spécifique.
Vous savez très bien. Il y a quelques
jours, j'ai assistais à la conférence
organisé par les autorités françaises
pour euh accorder de l'aide
supplémentaire à Liban qui traverse une
période très difficile liée aussi avec
la Syrie, avec la déstabilisation de la
Syrie.
La plus massive de migrants. Oui.
Oui. Et d'où
je reviens ici à notre conception
principale. La stabilisation de la Syrie
va stabiliser la situation dans la
région en tout cas va contribuer à la
stabilisation de la région. Les réfugiés
syriens reviendront de la Turquie, de
Jordanie, du Liban. Ça va apaiser la
situation dans tous ces pays. Ça va
améliorer la situation en Syrie. Voilà
pourquoi nous expliquons à tout le monde
que d'abord il faut trouver la solution
politique à la crise syrienne. Il faut
aider au syriens de régler euh de de de
finir avec cette longue guerre
fratricide.
La Chine. Est-ce que le la Chine vous
pose un problème quand on regarde dans
le nord de la Sibérie
la sinoïation de certains de vos
territoires ? Est-ce que est-ce que vous
avez peur que plus tard ces ces enclaves
chinoises fassent sécessions vous
demandent de se faire attacher à la
Chine ? Est-ce que ça vous pose un
problème au niveau de votre démographie
? Est-ce que c'est pour ça que vous
facilitez les rapports avec la Chine ?
Quel est votre avis ?
Bon, tous ces pronostics, c'est un peu
ils sont un peu fantasistes.
Vous avez combien de flux migratoires
dans le nord de la Russie au niveau de
la Chine ?
En tout cas, en tout cas euh tous les
citoyens chinois qui sont euh présents
sur le sur le sur le russe euh se
trouvent là-bas
absolument légitimement. Tout est réglé
par les accords bilatéraux entre la
Chine et la Russie. Tout est contrôlé
par notre service euh fédéral de
migration ou plutôt par le ministère de
l'intérieur. Donc tout c'est tout tout
cette présence est bien encadrée et bien
organisée. Nous n'avons pas de problème
avec des euh avec une migration
illégitime ou avec le trafic des
migrants qui vient de la Chine. Non,
non, non. Les Chinois, ce sont des gens
très sérieux, tout est bien organisé. Il
travaille en Russie euh beaucoup dans
l'agriculture. Oui, ils sont présents
euh euh dans l'extrême Orient euh russe.
Mais il faut pas exagérer euh quand
même, il faut pas exagérer. Euh ils sont
assez nombreux mais tout cela s'inscrit
dans les relations euh du partenariat
stratégique, des relations privilégiées
entre la Russie et la Chine. Les Russes
vont très nombreux en Chine. Euh
vraiment,
il y a une
forte inter pénétration des des gens.
Les gens les gens viennent, les Chinois
viennent travailler chez nous. Les
Russes viennent comme des touristes en
Chine pour faire des achats et cetera.
Donc vraiment, c'est une vraie
coopération transfrontalière. Et
globalement la Chine quand je vous ai
dit c'est c'est notre partenaire
stratégique avec lequel nous avons des
milliers de de de sujets euh des liens
développés dans tout le domaine une
coopération très forte dans le domaine
politique économique commercial
scientifique culturel nous sommes très
liés par l'histoire qui d'ailleurs
n'était pas toujours très simple mais
aujourd'hui vraiment il y a pas de nuage
dans le ciel des relation
franco russeis.
Est-ce que vous pensez Est-ce que vous
pensez pour parler trivialement
que les occidentaux vous cherche des
crosses parce que vous êtes un ennemi
facile pour pouvoir toucher la Chine qui
monte en puissance, le dragon chinois se
réveille. Est-ce que vous pensez que
vous êtes, comme on dit trivialement en
français, le dindon de la farce d'un
billard à trois bandes ?
Euh franchement, franchement, je ne
pense pas. Je ne pense pas parce que euh
l'Occident comprend très bien
queaujourd'hui euh la Russie et euh la
Chine, ce sont deux partenaires à euh
absolument objectif. Euh euh nous
partageons la même vision du monde qui
n'est pas partagée d'ailleurs par nos
partenaires occidentaux.
Votre vision du monde, c'est laquelle ?
Notre vision du monde, c'est que le
monde change et très rapidement. Euh
c'est un monde multipolaire, ce qui ne
veut pas dire que c'est un monde où on
perd le contrôle, mais c'est un monde où
chacun doit respecter un autre. Et pour
l'Occident, je pense que l'accident
considère les changements euh
qui se passent aujourd'hui dans le monde
comme la perte.
Comment appeler un chat ? Un chat,
c'est-à-dire que l'Occident qui perd en
puissance
Absolument. C'est absolument c'est
absolument
euh euh incontestable
incontestable. Euh l'Occident perd sa
domination qui a duré pendant 5 siècles,
même plus. Euh l'Occident euh euh
vit euh cette perte de domination euh
absolument total euh domination après la
euh 2e guerre mondiale ou plutôt
justement après la 2è guerre mondiale,
c'était partage des pouvoirs entre
l'Union Soviétique et euh l'Occident.
Mais après 91, après la disparition,
après l'effondrement de l'Union
Soviétique, au lieu de créer une
nouvelle architecture sécuritaire dans
le monde et en Europe, l'Occident euh a
bien cru que c'est lui qui a gagné la
guerre froide. Tandis que nous tous,
nous avons gagné, nous tous, la Russie a
gagné aussi parce que la Russie s'est
libéré d' régime autoritaire
sans verser en seul goût de sang en tout
cas.
avec des pertes minimales et au lieu de
créer ensemble au nouvel ordre mondial
au nouveau monde basé sur le primat de
la droit internationale, malheureusement
malheureusement l'Occident a choisi a
choisi une autre voie, une autre option.
Et voilà pourquoi quand nous parlons
aujourd'hui de la crise en Geéorgie, euh
de la crise en Ukraine, il faut bien
comprendre que toutes ces crises,
c'était pas le comment disais-je les les
les causes de l'aggravation de du
refroidissement actuel dans les
relations entre l'Occident et la Russie,
mais c'était déjà le résultat de la
politique
absolument incorrecte de l'égard du
monde et y compris à l'égard de la
Russie. Je répète euh malheureusement
euh nous avons perdu la chance qui nous
a donné la disparition dans euh disons
dans les circonstances absolument
pacifiques de l'Union Soviétique.
On va on va ouvrir une petite
parenthèse. On on reviendra à la
géopolitique après.
Vous avez un petit peu entendu parler de
des ingérences
russes dans la politique américaine,
française et peut-être ailleurs.
Dans le référendum à en Catalonie,
les élections parlementaires au Mexique,
nous sommes partout.
Fait du bon boulot, ça marche bien.
Oui, paraît-il. Euh et euh si on euh si
si si on dit que euh c'est les
États-Unis qui ont créé, qui ont inventé
l'internet, donc paraît-il que les
hackurs euh russes euh sont devenus
vraiment euh des hackers les plus forts
dans le monde. Mais euh
vraiment je n'ai aucun aucune envie de
de de de plaisanter sur ce sujet sur ce
sujet-là parce que euh ça devient tout à
fait ridicule et à mon avis humiliant
pour les pays qui expliquent tout ce
problème tous ces problèmes par cette
engérance emprouvée de de la Russie.
C'est tout à fait ridicule. Bon alors,
j'ai j'ai euh j'ai un ami qui a fait un
un documentaire sur
qui s'appelle Paul Morera et et on a
regardé de très près son documentaire
Garde l'info.
Est-ce que vous avez des commentaires ou
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler de
l'usine à troll de Saint-Pétersbourg ?
Il s'est déplacé sur place.
Il a été jusqu'au pied de l'immeuble.
On lui a dit, le gardien lui a dit
"Attention, je vais appeler le FSB."
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
des 400 trolls dans une usine à troll
censée
influencer la politique française,
américaine, anglaise, ukrainienne à
grand renfort d'astroturfing ? Est-ce
que vous démentez ? Est-ce que vous en
avez entendu juste parler ? Est-ce que
c'est votre état profond ou des
partisans ?
autonome d'une domination russe ou des
fans de Vladimir Poutine qui a pris
l'initiative
où il y a une porosité entre votre
gouvernement et cette usine à troll.
Est-ce que vous voulez des noms ?
Constantin Rikov,
ça vous parle ?
Timour Procopeno,
ça vous parle pas ?
Non, pas du tout. Donc écoutez euh je
n'ai aucune idée
sur ce sujet-là. Je sais que les rumeurs
existent et moi aussi je suis
utilisateur de l'internet et je
participe parfois dans les discussions
ici et là et j'ai entendu parler de ce
fabrique des trolls mais écoutez aucune
preuve sérieuse et surtout est-ce que
vous pensez que même 400 personnes si
ils jettent tous les ou ils mettent tous
leurs affaires de côté et se concentrent
sur la situation aux États-Unis
Est-ce que vous pensez que 400 personnes
peuvent vraiment influencer les
résultats des élections euh aux
États-Unis ou ?
Oui. Oui. Je c'est une question
rhtorique que je pos
Moi je dis oui,
moi je ne pense pas
400 comme nous payés à faire que ça.
Je ne comprends pas comment
techniquement je ne comprends pas
comment.
Est-ce que vous connaissez l'astrurfing
?
Non. L'astroturfing,
c'est l'équivalent d'une opération,
on appelle ça psyops,
c'est-à-dire utiliser grâce
à de la big data en faisant le profil
des gens pour exciter chez eux ou
activer chez eux leurs tendances ou
renforcer leurs tendances ou leur
opinion.
Cambridge Analytica, est-ce que ça vous
parle ?
Ah oui oui oui avec Facebook. Oui
avec Facebook ou Ouais.
Euh ça vous parle d'astrurfing ? Non
non non. Et euh bon euh peut-être euh je
ne suis pas en connaisseur des de ces
nouvelles technologies. Je comprends
très bien que c'est en principe les
technologies euh qui permet d'influencer
les gens pour acheter des produit pour
je sais pas prendre décision ça ça
existe peut-être. Mais euh écoutez euh
je ne peux pas imaginer que euh
les euh hackers russes, 400 ou même 4000
peuvent faire quelque chose euh pour
changer euh la vie de tel et tel euh euh
électeur américain et pour le faire
voter euh Donald Trump au lieu de
Hillary Clinton. Je ne crois pas à ça
et et surtout franchement je termine et
surtout
je ne pense pas que l'État russe
pourrait être derrière ces fabriques
absolument légendaires dont l'existence
n'est pas prouvée.
L'existence est prouvée.
Il y a des déclarations de Constantin
Rikov sur mediamrice.
filmé qui se revendique de cette de cet
astrurfing.
Est-ce que il est imaginable que l'État
russe s'intéresse à la société qui
s'appelle,
je vais vous retrouver le nom tout de
suite, qui s'appelle agence de relation
sur internet.
Est-ce que vous imaginez que l'étarus
puisse mettre un peu le nez dedans en
disant voilà qui qui est cette personne,
comment les financer et est-ce que les
soupçons des occidentaux ce reportage
est légitime ? C'est grave l'astrurfing
h écoutez euh
c'est supprimé c'est supprimer l'esprit
critique des gens les influençant
dans ma position je n'ai aucune
information à ce sujet.
Est-ce que vous pourrez revenir nous en
donner ? Euh je dois vraiment étudier la
question pour en revenir après, mais là
je peux rien vous dire. Je sais que euh
ma profonde conviction, c'est que chaque
résultat dans chaque pays, Brexit,
référendum en Catalonie, la victoire de
Donald Trump, la victoire de Victor
Orban, c'est les résultats des processus
très profonds et très sérieux qui se
passent dans chaque société, dans tous
ces pays que j'ai mentionné. La Russie
n'a pas
personne ne peut pas influencer. Sinon,
pensez-vous que
pensez-vous que quelqu'un peut
sérieusement
changer les états d'esprit des Russes
avant les élections présidentielles en
Russie ? Bah,
c'est pas possible. Les Russes, ils ont
déjà subi des années de propagande. Ils
savent reconnaître quand même. Vous avez
déjà discuté avec un Russ ? Non.
Très forcément. Non. Enfin vraiment euh
je sais euh la Russie euh et euh les
Russes et les structures étatiques
russes sont bien présent dans la sur
internet. Est-ce comp est-ce que vous
comprenez pourquoi je vous pose cette
question ? Est-ce que vous comprenez
pourquoi je vous pose ce type de
question ? Ah bah parce que on parle
beaucoup de ce trôle beaucoup de cette
ingérance
russe dans différentes élections. Mais
je peux nier en bloc toutes ces
accusations. C'est la seule chose que je
peux faire. Euh personnellement, je ne
crois pas que cette engérance
pourrait être très efficace. Mais je
dois vous dire une chose, euh je
n'exclus pas qu'il y a des groupes des
gens, des rckerss quand même, ils sont
pas contrôlés tous par l'État. Il y a
des gens qui euh peuvent euh euh
entreprendre certains certaines choses,
certains euh démarches, certains euh
certaines activités mais à titre
personnel ou bon même s'ils sont
organisés en quelques bon en équipe,
c'est pas obligéement l'État qui est
derrière eux. L'Étatus
s'occupe d'internet de façon très
sérieuse parce que le la menace théor
des des des terroristes euh les
nationalistes, les radicaux, les les les
comment la propagande extrémiste,
néonaziste et cetera, ça nous inquiète
beaucoup. Et voilà où euh les services
d'État euh voilà où ils sont présents.
Il y a des gens, je pense au FSB qui
contrôle les réseaux, essayent de
trouver des groupes néonazies ou des
hooligans de football ou je sais pas
quoi. Essay de de voir de contrôler tout
ça, c'est normal et c'est logique.
organiser une engérance massive dans les
affaires euh
partout un petit peu dans le monde parce
que je répète c'est c'est incroyable.
Euh j'ai entendu déjà une version que hm
en nom politique mexicain euh
parle déjà de cette érence éventuelle
dans les élections parlementaires au
Mexique. Mais vraiment euh ça prend déjà
euh une forme envoyés
le Mexique c'est un très beau pays et
je m'en doute pas je m'en doute pas mais
quand même. Bon, alors est-ce que vous
comprenez maintenant que l'État français
passe une loi sur les fake news
en ciblant nommément Rouatou des France
et Spoutnik ?
Mais non, je vous rappelle quand même
que
Rachet Today et Spoutnik ont reçu la
licence de l'État français et travaill
en France comme d'autres masséas
étrangers. Euh il y a quelques problèmes
de communication avec le palais de
l'Élysée. C'est vrai. Mais
il faut développer
par ça il travaille et il fonctionne
très bien. Et
je sais que les structures de l'État
français qui sont responsables pour
observation des activités des mass
médiia contrôlent tout. C'est ça.
Et oui et euh je répète, il y a une
licence qui a été délivrée et nos
journalistes travaillent. Quels sont
quels sont les problèmes de
communication entre vos médias et
l'Élysée ?
Bon euh vous avez entendu la conférence
de presse à Versailles le 29 mai quand
le président Macron a accueilli le
président russe avec sa visite en France
et leur première rencontre euh
personnelle. Euh vous avez entendu euh
combien il était sévère à l'égard de euh
Rachet et Spoutnik. Euh nous ne pouvons
pas partager son approche, mais
paraît-il que le service de presse de
Pot de l'Élysée a pris quelques
décisions et voilà et là ils ont le
droit de faire le
c'est leur politique de communication
avec ces deux euh mass médiia russes.
Mais nous avons déjà fait euh comprendre
à nos amis et à nos partenaires français
que euh
ça rend le travail
de ces deux structures
de la presse russe un peu plus
difficile, mais finalement j'espère que
on jour ça va s'améliorer. Et en tout
cas, je répète, Rashday et Sputnik
travaillent en France sans rencontrer
beaucoup de problèmes majeurs. S'ils
n'ont pas réussi à assister à quelques
conférences de presse au Pet l'Élysée,
c'est très euh c'est très dommage. Euh
c'est un peu décevant. Euh mais je pense
que euh il y a beaucoup plus
d'événements en France qu'il faut euh
décrire, accompagner et porter la
connaissance des spectateurs. Donc faut
pas exagérer le problème.
C'est c'est quand même une loi sur les
fake news avec vos médias désignés
nommément.
Certains analystes, certains
commentateurs de télévision disent que
c'est pour prévenir une future ingérence
de la Russie dans les élection
européenne.
Pour vous si si vous aviez
mon courage, qu'est-ce que je peux vous
dire ? Faites le nécessaire pour éviter
cette ingérence.
Le si vous aviez à voter en Europe, vous
voteriez pour qui ? Non, je peux pas
vous donner la réponse parce que il est
très difficile pour moi de me mettre à
la place dans européen. Euh vous parlez
des des des groupes des partis ou vous
parlez de la France concrètement ?
Des partis et de la France concrètement.
Euh comme chaque électeur, euh j'ai le
droit de garder cette information et ne
pas vous donner
personnel.
Ouais, accepter accepter. Cambridge
Analytica,
si on se rend compte un peu plus tard
que des Russes ont un petit peu
travaillé avec eux pour faire des
profils, qu'est-ce que vous vous allez
faire ? Vous allez convoquer ces gens
pour leur demander ce qu'ils ont fait de
leur propre initiative ?
Là, vous parlez de
Je parle d'un monsieur qui s'appelle
Constantin Rikov.
Je le connais pas ce monsieur-là.
Vous voulez pas vous renseigner un peu
sur lui ? Ben peut-être après, mais il
représente quelle structure ? Vous avez
dit
ce serait euh un un un chef, du moins,
ce serait le le responsable de la
colonie de vacances des trolls russes de
Saint-Pétersbourg.
Mais écoutez, nous revenons toujours à
ces fameux trolls. Mais nous n'avons
écoutez ce que je peux vous dire avec
toute franchise, c'est que l'ambassade
de Russie en France n'a pas de lien avec
des trolls euh
en Russie, enbourg ou ou que ce soit.
Nous n'avons, je pense que tout ça ce
sont des spéculations surtout euh et euh
je m'aime je je ne comprends pas
qu'est-ce que je peux vous raconter. Je
n'ai aucune idée vraiment.
Telegram Telegram, ça vous parle ?
Telégramm. Oui, Telegram. Euh mais c'est
une affaire euh euh de la justice russe.
Euh vous savez que euh Telégram devait
euh respecter euh certaines dispositions
de la législation russe. Ils n'ont pas
voulu. Euh voilà pourquoi Roscom Nazor,
notre structure qui s'occupe euh voilà
euh qui est chargé de euh contrôler un
petit peu le fonctionnement des réseaux
sociaux euh et qui a demandé Telegram de
présenter certaines informations
nécessaires pour les services de
renseignement de contrôler pour qu'il
puisse avoir l'accès au euh disons aux
échanges douteux
au messag au message chiffré. Ils ont
répondu non. Euh Roscomzor
euh euh s'est adressé à la justice russe
et le bon et maintenant c'est la
procédure judicière qui est en cours.
Quand vous voyez le le Américains
auditionner euh les patrons de Twitter
et de Facebook en disant "Il y a eu de
la pub politique pendant les élections
et cette pub politique était payée avec
des roubles. Euh ça vous fait penser à
quoi ? Est-ce que la Russie a le droit
de sponsoriser ses propres publications
? Est-ce que des groupes russes ont le
droit ? Il faut avoir plus de détails.
Il faut avoir plus de détails. Nous
avons dit déjà à mentre prise à nos
partenaires américains euh si vous nous
accusez d'engérance dans vos affaires
intérieures, faites-nous parvenir
des détails, des informations. Comment
vous pouvez faire cette conclusion que
sont les Russes qui sont derrière que
l'État russe est derrière telle ou telle
action ? Donnez-nous des détails. Je
peux vous dire que jusqu'aujourd'hui,
aucune demande formelle n'a été déposée.
Aucune information concrète n'a été
déposé. Là, vous parlez des affaires
américaines américaines, nous n'avons
rien à voir avec ça.
Si euh par le plus grand des hasards,
pendant les élections européennes, la
loi sur sur les fake news s'active
contre le média Riatoud ou le média
Spoutnik,
vous comptez faire le par le
parallélisme des formes la même le même
type d'opération, c'est-à-dire expulser
des médias comme France 24.
Non non non, il faut pas il faut pas euh
aller si loin. Attendons les élections.
Attendons attendons euh une première
décision de ou plutôt euh une première
utilisation réelle pratique de cette loi
sur Mais non, la loi elle n'est pas elle
n'a pas encore été adoptée, n'est-ce pas
?
Il est il est en il est en cours de
d'élaboration. Donc d'abord, il faut
attendre cette loi. Après, on va voir
comment les autorités, l'État français
va euh va va utiliser en pratique cette
loi. Bon, on va voir après.
Est-ce que vous voyez un un un sujet que
vous voulez aborder juste avant de
commencer le terrorisme, la partie
terroriste et flux migratoire ?
Euh, ça c'est notre
son sujet à suivre. Non, les sujets à
suivre, c'est le terrorisme, les flux
migratoires.
Ben écoutez, passons au terrorisme
tout de suite.
Oui.
Les flux migratoires, comment ça se
passe ? Est-ce que vous êtes inquiet par
le réchauffement climatique, les flux
migratoires inhérents au réchauffement
climatique et les flux les flux
migratoires inhérents aux guerres ?
Quelles sont les mesures proactives que
vous faites ? Est-ce que vous avez des
partenariats avec l'Europe pour gérer ça
? Est-ce que vous avez une prospective
à échanger avec nous ?
Ouais. Bon, tout d'abord,
nous avons nos propres problèmes
migratoires évidemment
qui sont
ce sont des migrants qui viennent
surtout de l'ex pays membre de l'Union
soviétique, des ex Républiques de
l'Union soviétique aujourd'hui les États
indépendants. Euh je pense surtout
au pays de l'Asie centrale. Euh nous
avons beaucoup de migrants qui viennent
de la Moldavie, de l'Ukraine et même de
la Bélorussie. Euh donc nous n'avons pas
de problème avec des migrants qui
viennent du proche et du Moyen-Orient.
Euh c'est très loin pendant cette crise
avec des des migrants, certains ont
passé par le territoire russe pour aller
au Flande par exemple ou en Norvège.
Mais vraiment c'était des facteurs
plutôt
marginaux dans le contexte global. Donc
nous avons nos propres problèmes. Il
faut dire que euh tous ces
ressortissants des pays de l'Asie
centrale euh n'ont pas besoin d' visa
pour venir en Russie. Donc il y a
d'autres euh accords bilatéraux qui
règlent euh les euh les relations de ce
domaine, mais euh les gens peuvent venir
euh sans demander le visa et nous
n'allons pas nous n'allons aucune
intention de changer cette situation
parce que bon pour nous, nous vivons le
même espace post-sovétique. Nous avons
euh nous nous nous faisions beaucoup
pour promouvoir euh l'intégration
des pays euh partenaires des pays de
l'ex bloc soviétique de l'exunion
soviétique. Donc c'est un problème
plutôt c'est un sujet très politique
pour nous. Nous voulons approfondir les
liens, nous voulons resserrer les liens
avec nos anciens compatriotes. Mais les
problèmes dans ce domaine existent. Il
faut tout simplement établir les règles.
Comment réguler réguler tout ça,
régulariser tout ça, comment mieux
organiser leur vie en Russie, euh
comment mieux contrôler euh la situation
du point de vue sécuritaire parce que
évidemment il y a la criminalité entre
eux dans leur communauté. Il y a la
criminalité qui touche les Russes euh
les euh les les citoyens russes. Il y a
euh la participation de certains
éléments euh dans la crime organisée,
dans le trafic de la drogue et cetera.
Il y a les migrants euh qui travaillent
sans bien remplir des documents,
c'est-à-dire migration illégitime, tout
ça existe. Euh nous avons plusieurs
formats au sein de la communauté des
indépendants, au sein de l'Union
Euroasiatique, Union économique
euroaitique euh qui se forme euh
aujourd'hui. Donc nous parlons à tous
nos partenaires à titre bilatéral, mais
avec l'Europe, nous avons aussi un
dialogue qui concerne ce problème pour
justement pour trouver ensemble les
moyens pour arrêter le trafic des êtres
humains, les trafics de tout de tout de
tout genre pour éviter la migration
illégale par le territoire russe.
Effectivement, nous avons ce dialogue.
Il y a euh des experts russes et de
l'Union européenne qui se réunissent.
Aujourd'hui, il faut dire que dans euh
dans dans la situation de euh ce
rafroidissement que nous avons déjà
évoqué, euh tous les formats de
coopération euh avec l'Union européenne
ne marche pas euh très bien, mais on
maintient toujours les dialogues sur les
migration, sur la coopération possible.
Mais euh et justement nous constatons
que parmi les méfis les menaces et les
défis qui existent devant nous et où
nous pouvons coopérer de façon efficace
figure également le problème de
migration illégale.
J'ouvre une petite parenthèse histoire
de vous déconcentrer. On a vu on a vu
dans nos médias une loi qui permet de
on va dire de pas de légaliser les
violences domestiques mais de de
s'arranger
quand les femmes se font un petit peu
tabasser par leur mari
de payer une amende ou quelque chose
comme ça. Est-ce que c'est vrai ? C'est
pas vrai ? Est-ce que le cette loi est
une dégradation de la condition de la
femme en Russie ? Est-ce que c'est fait
pour éviter d'engorger les tribunaux
parce que la population russe devient de
plus en plus stressée ?
Ah, je comprends, je comprends de quoi
parlait. Non, mais écoutez
euh euh évidemment, bon euh
une loi a été adoptée, mais évidemment
euh c'est une loi qui euh qui qui
n'améliore pas la situation des gens,
des mecs qui tabassent leur euh copines
ou euh concubines ou femme, mais euh
c'est quelque chose qui décriminalise
euh euh les incidents mineurs euh dans
ce domaine de la vie familiale.
Évidemment, la femme est protégée par la
législation. Évidemment,
euh quand il s'agit d'une acte
d'agression grave, c'est pénalisé de
façon très très ferme et sérieuse. En ce
qui concerne l'état de femmes en Russie,
ben écoutez euh moi jamais je ne
frappais euh ni mon épouse ni mes
copines à l'époque et je ne même pas
imaginer comment euh un mec peut frapper
une femme.
C'est inimaginable.
Pour moi, c'est inimaginable. Mais je
comprends que ça arrive. Euh dans mon
entourage, jamais j'ai entendu parler
des choses pareilles. Les femmes, elles
peuvent frapper les les mecs, ça c'est
vrai de temps en temps. Mais comme ça
euh un tout petit peu, je plaisante
évidemment, mais euh mais mais ce
problème existe en Russie comme dans
tous les pays du monde. Chez nous, il y
a des assassinats. On frappe les femmes
jusqu'à la mort. Ça arrive, c'est une
tragédie, c'est un crime et c'est
pénalisé de façon très très ferme. Il
n'y a pas de d'aucune, comment dirais-je
euh tolérance euh à cet égard. Euh la
Russie c'est un pays où euh la femme a
toujours été très respectée. Euh on
adore les femmes même si euh nos
sociétés sont différentes. Euh les
traditions sont un peu différentes.
C'est une tradition de
Non, je je veux dire que euh aujourd'hui
le niveau d'émancipation des femmes en
Russie est moins élevé que dans certains
des pays européens. Mais même en Europe,
c'est différent. En Europe, il y a les
pays scandinaves où euh l'égalité
vraiment euh entre les femmes et les
hommes fait partie des priorités
absolues, n'est-ce pas, de l'État. Il y
a d'autres pays euh où euh la situation
la situation est un peu différente.
C'est vrai, les sociétés la société
russe et les sociétés européenne sont un
peu différentes. Nous avons euh
peut-être d'autres traditions. Euh la la
société russe euh
est plus conservatif en général. Euh il
y a plus de sexistes chez nous que
peut-être en Finlande, mais chacun a son
rythme. Notre société, notre société se
développe euh toujours. Et je vous
rappelle que en France, les femmes ont
reçu le droit de voter en 1944.
Tandis que même à l'époque soviétique,
les femmes et même je peux me tromper
mais je pense que déjà après la
révolution de 1905
euh les femmes ont déjà reçu le droit de
voter lors des élections des premiers
domas d'état de la Russie. Mais en tout
cas, après la social après la révolution
d'octobre, les femmes ont reçu le droit
de vote immédiatement. Euh et en général
euh il faut dire que l'Union soviétique
euh la Russie soviétique a libéré la
femme et non seulement en Russie mais
surtout dans les dans les Républiques
nationales. C'est un vrai émergence
d'une femme. Euh la femme euh
est entrée dans la vie politique, dans
la vie sociale, dans la vie culturelle.
Donc si nous prenons l'histoire, mon
pays vraiment a beaucoup donné euh aux
femmes. Et si aujourd'hui nous revenons
par exemple à l'histoire de ce pauvre
pays Afghanistan qui traverse toujours
une période d'instabilité, mais je peux
vous dire que c'est juste c'est
justement à l'époque de cette ingérence
soviétique
où la femme afghane se sentait plus
euh libre que avant et après.
On a on a trois questions de notre
communauté qui nous arrivent en direct
d'internet. Euh, comment ça va en Russie
pour les homosexuels,
le les LGBT ?
Euh, je réponds tout de suite. D'abord,
avec toute franchise, je reconnais que
euh la société russe reste très
conservative,
conservatrice ou homophob conservatrice
à ce sujet. Oui, il y a des homophobes.
Il y a des homophobes, c'est sûr, mais
je pense que les homophobes existent
partout. Peut-être chez nous, ils sont
plus nombreux que en France, par
exemple.
Mais mais déjà,
je reviens toujours à l'époque
soviétique, nous avons déjà fait
beaucoup de progrès dans ce domaine là
parce que à l'époque soviétique, l'omo
l'omo l'homosexualité était tout
simplement pénalisée par le code pénal.
Les gens pouvaient aller en prison
aussi chez nous, hein.
Voilà. Mais chez vous, c'était jusqu'à
quelle année ? Je sais pas. En tout cas,
chez nous c'était presque jusqu'à la fin
de l'Union soviétique. Donc aujourd'hui,
on a rien à voir avec ça. Les gens
restent,
disons assez perplexes à ce sujet-là.
Euh oui, nous ne donnons pas la
permission à l'organisation de Gate
Pride, mais je pense
c'est sympa la Gay Pride, il faut
organiser une G Pride à Moscou sur la
place rouge.
Ah oui, mais le moment n'est pas venu,
je vous dis franchement. Mais euh à ma
connaissance, en Pologne ou en Grèce,
euh c'est un peu compliqué aussi de
d'organiser les manifestations
pareilles. Je ne veux pas dire que c'est
c'est c'est bien ou c'est mal. C'est
c'est du bien ou c'est du mal. Mais euh
je veux vous expliquer que euh oui euh
pour l'instant nous sommes là où nous
sommes. Euh les hommes en général les
homosexuels se sont assez bien en
Russie. Ils ne peuvent pas registrer
leur mariage, c'est vrai, mais ils ont
les endroits où ils peuvent se réunir.
Il y a des bars, il y a des restaurants.
Tout simplement chez nous. Euh pour
l'instant nous les gens ne manifestent
pas très comment dirais comment
dirais-je euh h ses relations
manifestées dans la rue. Bon oui, ça
peut provoquer quelques
Vous parlez de la vidéo qui a beaucoup
tourné sur internet de de d'une caméra
cachée où euh un couple d'hommes
marchait main dans la main et se faisait
rabrouer d'une façon violente
h
par des des gens pas très contents de
les voir marcher main main dans la main.
Oui, c'est c'est c'est ctait filmé. Donc
euh je peux je peux rien vous vous dire
à ce sujet. Oui,
les gens les gens pour l'instant les
gens ils sont comme ça.
Si vous vous voyez ce type de réaction,
ça vous inspire quoi ?
Oui, écoutez, je je n'accepte aucune
agressivité et aucune violence. Euh moi
euh dans ce cas-là, j'espère que
j'essaierai de m'impliquer pour arrêter
une bagarre ou je sais pas quoi, mais
pour vous dire toute la vérité,
monsieur, moi je suis personnellement,
je suis très
J'espère que vous me dites toute la
vérité depuis le départ là.
Oui, évidemment. Euh mais euh moi
personnellement euh je suis pas
quelqu'un de très public euh je suis
assez libéral. Euh je suis euh
comment dire je suis très tolérant mais
si je vois euh deux jeunes hommes dans
le métro qui vont s'embrasser devant mes
yeux, je vais tourner la tête parce que
et si c'est deux femmes ?
Non, je ne tourne pas la tête.
C'est bizarre, c'est comme ça, mais
c'est de de la psychologie peut-être ou
physiologie, je ne sais pas. Mais quand
je vois deux hommes, oui, c'est mon truc
euh à moi, je vais plutôt mais jamais je
ne veux pas les accuser, mais je vais
tourner la tête parce que euh
c'est ça me ça me fait pas plaisir de
regarder les scènes pareilles. Mais moi,
je suis fils de mon pays. Moi aussi,
j'ai passé j'ai appris l'existence de de
de l'homosexualité
quand j'étais assez assez grand déjà
parce que euh à l'Union Soviétique, on
pouvait pas voir les choses pareilles.
la littérature classique, euh
l'histoire,
les les les articles avec la
transparence et glace no péistroica,
tous ces thèmes sont devenus connus et
cetera. J'ai bien réalisé, j'ai bien
compris que c'est la nature. Et après,
je suis venu en France, j'ai écouté
cette magnifique chanson de Charles
Navour comme ils disent. Et euh voilà,
euh
cette chanson m'a touché beaucoup. Euh
cette chanson h euh m'a permis d'évoluer
un petit peu mes propres euh approches,
mes propres sentiments. Euh et jamais je
n'accuserai les gens pour ce type de
comportement. C'est pas mon truc, mais
je comprends que c'est comme ça. C'est
c'est la vie.
Question d'internet. Euh souhaitez-vous
leur donner plus de droits ? parce que
le gouvernement russe compte donner plus
de droits aux homosexuels et vous à
titre personnel.
Écoutez, avec du temps peut-être, mais
il y a des choses euh que moi-même euh
je n'accepte pas. Euh euh l'adoption des
enfants, par exemple euh ou euh pourquoi
?
Pourquoi ?
parce que je pense que ça peut limiter
ça peut ça peut dicter la choix à cet
enfant-là après. Mais vraiment c'est un
sujet très délicat, très délicat,
il faut être très très prudent, très
délicat avec ça, mais euh je je
reconnais que euh
c'est pas la question de demain pour
pour la Russie. Alors, je vais vous en
poser deux autres avant de de fermer ce
ce cette parenthèse. Euh les homosexuels
en Cheetchen, ça vous parle ? Leurs
conditions, leurs façons dont ils sont
euh traités ?
Euh là euh je ne peux pas opérer
d'effets concrets, les rumeurs qui
existaient et notre boots euh s'occuper
euh de très près de ces situations.
À ma connaissance,
les rumeurs n'ont pas été confirmées par
les faits concrets et moi-même, je n'ai
jamais vu aucun
Il y a pourtant beaucoup il y a beaucoup
d'associations qui s'occupent de
peut-être, mais je n'ai vu aucun photo,
aucun récit,
comment dirais-je confirmé avec une
personne qui a subi un tel traitement et
qui a dû fuir, quitter la tutunie. Je
n'exclus pas que euh ces cas ont ont eu
lieu. Je n'exclus pas. En plus, sachez
que la société,
la en général la société dans le dans
les Républiques euh du Caucas du Nord
russe, si notre société est
conservatrice. Donc imaginez-vous là,
c'est 10 fois plus euh conservatrice
parce queil faut multiplier par de Moyen
Âge.
C'est Non, non, non, écoutez, Moyen-Âge
quand même, c'est c'est trop fort. Mais
c'est différent parce que ils ont leur
propre tradition, leur leur leur propre
vision des choses.
Il faut répète, c'est très délicat.
C'est très délicat. Mais vous savez,
chaque la Russie c'est un pays vraiment
multiconfessionnel, multinational,
multiethnique, multiculturel.
Imaginez-vous, oui, ce sont des gens
parfois sévères, conservateurs, mais en
même temps, il y a pas des orphelans
dans ces Républiques du Cass du Nord. Ce
n'est pas possible. On peut pas laisser
un enfant qui a perdu ses parents comme
ça euh dans la rue ou dans la maison
spéciale. Les parents immédiatement
prend en charge cet enfant. Donc chaque
société, je répète a ces traditions très
c'est très spécifiques, il faut le
respecter.
Euh on a vu émerger sur internet dans
différents pays, y compris aux
États-Unis, je sais pas, je ne sais pas
pour la Russie, des banques de sperme où
on peut choisir des caractéristiques.
Vous avez vraiment des questions euh
spéciales ? Bah c'est c'est des
questions,
il ne posent pas les internautes, il ne
posent pas des questions sur la Syrie ou
rein ou précéuration.
On a vu des des banques de spermons
débarquer et où les gens les mères
porteuses ou les couples homosexuels ou
d'autres personnes pouvaient choisir les
yeux, la couleur des yeux, la la
des prédispositions génétiques
de leur de leur paillettes de sperme. Ça
vous inspire quoi ?
Bah qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça peut
m'inspirer ? Je sais que les
technologies dans la médecine
progressent. Euh parfois les gens euh
qui ne peuvent pas avoir des enfants,
c'est une seule option possible euh
quand l'un ou l'autre membre du couple
ne peut pas avoir des enfants.
Bon, écoutez, il y a des des aspects
éthiques, il y a des aspects morals,
mais c'est la choix de chaque personne
concrete.
La Russie se positionne au niveau de
l'éthique, comment face à ça ? Est-ce
que Est-ce que le le don de sperme est
anonyme ?
Euh non, c'est une question très
spécifique. Je ne sais pas. Mais ce que
je sais, je sais que les couples euh
même âgés euh grâce voilà à ces
nouvelles technologies peuvent avoir un
enfant avec soit avec une mère porteuse,
soit avec
la femme de la couple, mais qui est
l'objet de certains opérations
médicales. Et ça se pratique chez nous,
c'est c'est c'est légal.
Euh c'est normal, il y a des aspects, il
y a des aspects éthiques. Je répète,
quand on couple par exemple des gens
assez connus, des gens qui occupent une
place importante dans le showbiz et
cetera, les gens où la femme est plus
âgée que
que monsieur ou ils sont tous les deux
assez âgés ou ou au contraire ils sont
tous les deux en pleine forme mais quand
même ils utilisent ces technologies ou
ces possibilités que donne la mère
porteuse.
Ça provoque pas mal de spéculations dans
les mass médiia qui s'intéressent à la
vie des gens des people comme vous
dites.
Mais c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire. Il y a des gens qui accusent, les
autres qui approuvent mais
c'est c'est la pratique qui devient de
plus en plus courante chez nous. En tout
cas,
la Russie, l'intelligence artificielle,
comment ça se passe ? La protection des
données, comment vous vous positionnez
sur ces sujets-là ? Protection de
données, c'est quelque chose qui c'est
un sujet à lequel nous apportons
beaucoup d'importance et vraiment c'est
chose absolument cruciale, protéger les
données personnelles des gens. En ce qui
concerne euh
intelligence artificielle,
une sphère très spécifique, vraiment je
suis pas je ne suis pas un spécialiste,
je ne suis pas un expert, je peux rien
vous donner d'intéressant.
Question d'internet, comment va Snow ?
Euh, il est quelque part en Russie ou
ça, je ne sais pas, mais il est toujours
chez nous. Euh, mais je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qu'il fait. Peut-être il
s'occupe de euh de l'internet, peut-être
il fait son propre projet, je sais pas.
Mais il est toujours protégé par l'État
russe.
Vous avez un un point de vue sur les
cryptomonnaies. Est-ce que la Russie
s'intéresse aux cryptomonnaaies ? Est-ce
que la Russie compte développer sa
propre cryptomie ?
Oui, il s'intéresse. Il y a des gens euh
il y a des gens euh qui qui
s'intéressent et qui même qui
investissent euh dans les crypto
monnaies. Euh et même j'ai un membre de
la famille qui a acheté en comment elle
s'appelle déjà ? Euh
Bitcoin.
Bitcoin. l'acheté en Bitcoin euh et
encore quelques quelques types de crypto
cryptomonnaie, mais je sais que euh la
législation pour l'instant n'est pas
encore établie. Euh il y a pas il y a
pas des structures qui peuvent réguler
euh ce nouveau cette nouvelle forme euh
des relations économiques.
Et je sais que euh il y a beaucoup de
scepticisme scepticisme
euh euh à l'égard de euh cette monnaie.
Il y a des économistes de renom euh qui
prédictent la chute totale de de de
cette dévise, mais qui sait peut-être au
contraire, c'est l'avenir de notre de du
système financier du monde.
Est-ce que vous comptez développer une
cryptomonnaie avec la Chine euh adossée
à de l'or ?
Euh pour à ma connaissance, ce projet
pour l'instant n'existe pas et et et à
ma connaissance, l'État comme tel est
assez réticent euh à l'égard de ce
sujet. Nous avons vraiment d'autres
chats à foueter. Euh il y a plusieurs
d'autres problèmes. Le moment de
cryptoonnaie n'est pas venu.
On va alors on va parler d'un gros chat.
Euh l'indépendance monétaire de la
Russie face au dollars, vous la vous la
concevez comment ?
C'est suable. Je pense parce que ben
prenez euh lesaventures des banques
françaises frappées par la justice
américaine pour ses relations
économiques et financières avec tel ou
tel pays. Euh parler de la BNP. Oui oui
oui. Par exemple, donc euh je pense que
c'est dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
que euh euh comment dirais-je
l'inventail des vises reconnues
intentionnellement soit plus large que
dollars et euros. Mais nous sommes des
réalistes. Nous comprenons que notre
économie n'est pas suffisamment
puissante pour euh entrer dans cette
aventure. Mais ce que nous essayons de
développer, c'est les échanges avec nos
partenaires euh régionaux, y compris la
Chine, dans le cadre, par exemple de
l'Organisation de coopération de
Shangai. euh on veut promouvoir la
pratique euh d'utilisation des euh
nationales dans les échanges entre les
euh collègues, entre les euh pays
membres de telle ou telle organisation
régionale.
Mais euh je répète, nous sommes nous
sommes des réalistes. Nous comprenons
que euh pendant des années et des années
et des années, l'économie mondiale sera
encrée à le dollar et peut-être à
l'euro.
Le pétro yan, ça vous inspire quoi ?
Petro yan
c'est du pétrole tradé en y non question
en sujet trop spécifique
swift comment se positionne la Russie
face à Swift
nous faisons partie du système bancaire
du monde entier du système global et
je ne peux pas imaginer combien comment
la Russie aussi bien que tous ses
partenaires étrangers pourraient vivre
sans en Swift parce que euh bon euh
c'est quelque chose qui euh qui assure
le bon fonctionnement de la commerce
extérieur et tout le monde est intéressé
de préserver ce système.
Quand il y a eu des des sanctions contre
la Russie
au moment de la Crimée et que la Russie
s'est fait un petit peu sortir de Swift
?
Non non, jamais jamais. Bon euh non, la
Russie n'avait aucun euh aucune volonté,
aucun désir de sortir de Swift et jamais
euh euh euh jamais euh personne de nos
partenaires occidentaux n'évoquaient pas
la possibilité de couper la Russie de ce
Swift. Et en plus, je ne sais pas si
c'est possible techniquement ou non.
Peut-être techniquement c'est possible,
mais ça va vraiment embêter énormément
les milieux d'affaires étrangers qui euh
euh qui sont très présents en Russie,
qui continuent à coopérer avec la
Russie.
Autre question d'internet, la Russie
va-t-elle participer à une monnaie
asiatique ?
Enf on va voir en tout cas nous nous
renforçons nos liens avec
les différents partenaires par
l'intermédiaire de cette grande
organisation organisation de coopération
de Shanghaiï on va on va examiner tout
ça on va examiner cette option
nous sommes pour la diversification
du système financière global.
Il faut jamais mettre tous ces œufs dans
le même panier.
Vous avez euh vous pouvez nous parler de
la corruption en Russie ? On a vu
récemment une loi permettant au juges et
au procureur de pouvoir conduire
alcoolisé pour éviter de subir des
pressions de la police.
Euh vous voulez rebondir dessus ?
Bon euh
la corruption c'est un c'est un grand
problème de Russie qui est reconnu comme
tel.
C'est un fléo mais c'est un fléau qui
existe non seulement en Russie mais dans
plusieurs pays du monde. Personne n'est
épargné et je pense la France aussi.
Mais chez nous, c'est un problème majeur
et euh
c'est reconnu au niveau le plus haut. Et
voilà pourquoi les dirigeants du pays,
le président lui-même attache beaucoup
d'importance à la lutte contre la
corruption, tout en comprenant que euh
c'est la lutte qui prévoit plusieurs
plusieurs mesures. Vous savez que le
Chinois euh en luttant contre la
corruption euh ils utilisent la pein
capitale et par des dizaines de
personnes ou même voire centaines.
Il faut même payer la balle, non ? Euh
ça je ne sais pas mais en tout cas euh
je sais au contraire que la corruption
ne devient pas euh moins forte en Chine.
C'est toujours un très grand problème en
Russie aussi. Mais les dernières années,
si vous vous pouvez euh voir tout ça,
euh plusieurs
fonctionnaires très haut placés, les
gouverneurs,
les juges, les euh fonctionnaires, les
les les gradés euh euh de la milice de
la police, euh beaucoup de gens très
haut placés ont été arrêtés, jugés ou
attends
euh le tribunal pour les faits de la
corruption. Donc en principe, nous
menons les choses vers la situation où
personne n'est épargné. Mais évidemment,
nous avons encore une longue longue
chemin à faire. La corruption reste
toujours un problème majeur et les gens
le disent à nos dirigeants tout le
temps.
Question d'internet, quelle
communication avez-vous avec les
États-Unis en ce moment ? Euh
il s'agit d'une euh dégradation
euh très importante des relations entre
la Russie et les États-Unis. Peut-être
c'est
euh le pire état des relations depuis
euh l'effondrement de l'Union
soviétique. C'est très déplorable.
C'est pas la Russie qui était à
l'origine de cette situation.
Euh nous sommes toujours euh ouverts à
la coopération avec les Américains là où
nous pouvons coopérer et nous coopérons.
Nous coopérons toujours dans plusieurs
domaines, compris en Syrie. Il y a un
canal de communication entre les
militaires qui fonctionne très bien pour
euh éviter les malentendus dangereux,
pour éviter des accrochages accidentels
et cetera. Donc nous sommes ouverts mais
pour l'instant il faut dire que h
les choses ont pris une très mauvaise
tournure euh du point de vue d'une vraie
comment dire hystérie antirus à
Washington et aux États-Unis en général.
C'est vraiment un retour au temps de
macartisme. Euh vous savez, il y a
il y a un camout, il y a une un
phénomène de camenout. Aujourd'hui, ce
coming out concerne aux États-Unis,
concerne des hommes politiques, des
sénateurs, des congrès qui se déclarent
avoir eu un contact avec tel ou tel
diplomate russe ou l'ambassadeur russe
et cetera. Donc vraiment en vrai mais
coule pas pour un simple fait de contact
lors d'une réception ou dîner ou je sais
pas quoi. Donc vraiment c'est une folie
absolue. C'est c'est vraiment euh
c'est un petit peu irréel, c'est
difficile à imaginer mais
malheureusement c'est comme ça. Nous
traversons une période très très
difficile tout en restant évidemment en
contact. Euh vous savez que Donald Trump
a téléphoné à Vladimir Poutine pour le
féliciter, pour le congratuler à
l'occasion de sa victoire
impressionnante lors des élections
présidentielles et peu après euh il l'a
il a évoqué leur rencontre éventuelle
aux États-Unis dans la Maison Blanche.
Donc vous voyez que même dans ces
situations, le président américain, il
pense, il songe à
à établir à approfondir le dialogue avec
le président russe. Mais je répète, la
situation est très très
même dangereuse, je peux vous dire parce
que
le niveau de russophobie
a atteint vraiment
une grade très très élevée à Washington.
C'est les néoconservateurs qui poussent.
C'est le
Oui. Ben en tout cas plusieurs facteurs
ont joué je pense mais néoconservateur
peut-être plusieurs facteurs ont joué
leur rôle. Euh et tout d'abord les
résultats des élections présidentielles
qui pour nous ont manifesté on on on on
ont ont montré les états d'esprit, le
niveau des les états d'esprit parmi les
électeurs américains qui ont voulu
vraiment changer, qui ont voulu euh
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez vu ici en
France, les gens fatigués par les élites
classiques ont voulu élire une nouvelle
visage, une nouvelle personne. Ben, on
va voir comment ça va se passer la
prochaine fois. Mais en tout cas,
un résultat nous avons une
une une vraiment déteration des
relations avec la Russie.
Question d'Internet. Pourquoi il n'y
a-t-il plus de collaboration entre les
universités russes et françaises ?
C'est pas vrai. C'est pas vrai. Il y a
il y a 500 acts.
Pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas plus ? Autant
pour moi.
Ah euh
pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas plus de
collaboration entre les universités
françaises et russes ?
Nous le souhaitons et il faut vous dire
que la coopération scientifique et dans
le domaine de l'éducation entre la
Russie et la France euh se développe
très très bien. Euh et là je peux vous
dire que nous avons en conseiller à
l'ambassade qui s'occupe que des
relations dans le domaine de la
coopération scientifique et euh dans le
domaine de de l'éducation. Il y a 5000
étudiants russes en France, mais très
peu des étudiants français en Russie.
euh quelques petites centaines. Euh par
contre, les relations entre les
universités sont très denses. Euh il y a
plusieurs plus à ma connaissance, il y a
500 accords de coopération entre
différents euh établissements de l'école
supérieure russe française. Il y a
plusieurs programmes comment, il y a des
échanges. Non, ça se passe très bien
mais je suis d'accord, nous sommes nous
sommes persuadés qu'on peut faire mieux
et
approfondir davantage les relations, la
coopération dans ce domaineelà. Comment
ça se passe les visas ? Euh vous avez
des conseils à donner pour les visas ?
Imaginez-vous
avec Oui, oui.
J'ai j'ai euh j'ai c'est une question
personnel qui m'a été demandée par un
ami.
Comment on fait pour avoir un visa 6
mois pour aller en Russie ?
Il y a
pour rejoindre pour rejoindre sa moitié.
Oui. Non. Écoutez, il y a trois types de
visa. Visa d'affaires,
visa bon deux types de visa. Visa d'
trois trois quand même. Mission
officielle, visa d'affaires et visa
touristique. Mais il y a encore d'autres
possibilité. Vous êtes invité par un
proche, par membre de famille, par un
ami qui dép qui qui doit déposer euh
dans un département du ministère de
l'intérieur dans chaque arrondissement
de Mouscou ou dans chaque arrondissement
de la ville dans un département qui est
habilité à établir les invitations. Et
avec cette invitation, vous pouvez vous
adresser soit directement au service
consolaire euh mais plutôt au service de
visa euh à Paris.
et euh
déposer le dossier complet. For il faut
remplir un formulaire, coller en photo,
avoir en assurance. Mais écoutez, toutes
les explications, toute information est
disponible sur le site, mais je peux
vous dire que il y a pas de problème
avec des visas. 5 jours de travail, vous
avez votre visa en Russie. En ce qui
concerne les liens familiaux là euh il
faut préciser mais euh si vous avez
bah si vous êtes lié par le lien
familial avec une dame si je comprends
bien n'est-ce pas
non il est pas encore c'est sa copine
encore pas encore sa copine euh 6 mois
c'est à à ma connaissance un peu
compliqué mais on peut établir en visa
pour 3 mois je pense. En tout cas, tout
est faisable et en ce qui concerne les
visas, il y a pas de souci. Nous avons
nous avons
les consulats généraux à Marseille, à
Strasbourg. Nous avons une agence
consolaire
chancellerie
consolaire à Villefranche surmer et nous
avons le service consolaire à
l'ambassade.
Bon et globalement, ça se passe bien à
mon avis. Avant dernière question.
Si on repropose à l'ambassade américaine
de venir interagir avec vous et nous,
vous acceptez
avec une seule condition, on parle
français.
Parfait. L'ambassade de Suède, pareil.
Pareil.
Bon, il y a plus qu'à organiser un apéro
alors hein pour améliorer les choses.
Oui.
Dernière dernière question, vous la
connaissez ? laisser un un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
pour l'avenir.
Bon,
écoutez, je n'ai pas préparé en notre
conseil donc je reviens à ce que je déjà
dit surtout et vraiment c'est très
actuel dans l'état actuel des choses.
Euh il y a trop d'informations qui vient
d'ici et là. Je propose de comparer les
informations. Je propose de puiser les
différentes sources d'information. Je
propose de d'analyser, de réfléchir,
de voir, d'entrer en détail euh et de se
mettre à la place de notre de temps en
temps pour mieux comprendre pourquoi tel
ou tel pays interprend telle et telle
mesure ou euh effectue telle et telle
démarche politique
pour mieux comprendre. Donc réfléchir,
lire, étudier la question, analyser et
ne croire pas à la première information
qui arrive.
Monsieur Denikov, merci.
Merci à vous. Excellente soirée. Au
revoir. Coupéz.
[Musique]